I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, everybody. Hello. Welcome to Office, ladies. I'm so excited about this episode. It's so good, right? Yeah. And we reached out to lots of folks. So we have some fun, fun stuff. This is grief counseling. And guys, if we can get you depressed by the end of this podcast, we've done our job. Oh, Michael. It's season three, episode four, written by
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了“终极办公室重温”播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨。欢迎来到“办公室女士”。我对这一集超级期待。太棒了，对吧？是的。我们联系了很多人。所以我们有一些有趣、好玩的内容。这一集是“悲伤辅导”。伙计们，如果我们在本集播客结束时能让你们感到沮丧，那我们的工作就到位了。哦，迈克尔。这是第三季第四集，编剧是
Jen Salada and directed by Roger Nygaard. Jen Salada is one of my favorite people, Jenna. 100%. She is just such a delight and was so much fun on set because she would always crack up. Oh, yeah. She was one of our worst laughers, which made her the best laugher. Yeah. Hey, Jenna, you know what I'd love right now? I hope it's a summary. It's a summary. All right, here it is. Michael finds out that his former boss, Ed Truck, was decapitated in a self-induced drunk driving accident. Nobody seems upset, though, or certainly not upset enough, which causes Michael to question if anyone would care about his death. Of course, he doesn't know that that's what he's worried about. Yeah, he doesn't understand really
珍·萨拉达，导演是罗杰·奈加德。珍·萨拉达是我最喜欢的人之一，珍娜。百分之百。她简直太讨人喜欢了，在片场也总是充满乐趣，因为她总是忍不住大笑。哦，是的。她是我们当中笑点最奇特的人之一，这让她成为了笑得最好的人。是的。嘿，珍娜，你知道我现在最想要什么吗？我希望是个总结。是个总结。好吧，就是这样：迈克尔发现他的前老板埃德·特拉克在一次自己造成的酒驾事故中被斩首了。然而，似乎没有人感到难过，或者说难过得还不够，这让迈克尔开始怀疑是否有人会在乎他的死。当然，他并不知道这就是他真正担心的事。是的，他其实并不明白
the depths of his sadness. Yes. He wants everyone to love him and be sad for him if he wasn't around. Yeah, make a fuss about him. Well, first, he leads everyone in some grief counseling, but then later, he forces everyone to participate in a bird funeral. Meanwhile, over in Stanford, Jim is put in charge of supervising Karen for the day, but decides to put their work on hold so they can search for her favorite bag of chips. Oh, we're going to have so much to say about that. This is a really odd tangent, and I don't mean to take this really weird, really fast. Do it. Jenna, while I was re-watching this episode, I hear a commotion outside of my, that's what she said. No. And a squirrel is eating a little bird. That's worse than
他悲伤的深度。是的。他希望每个人都爱他，如果他不在了，大家都会为他难过。是的，为他大惊小怪。好吧，首先，他带领大家进行了一些悲伤辅导，但随后，他强迫每个人参加一场小鸟葬礼。与此同时，在斯坦福，吉姆负责监督卡伦一天的工作，但决定把工作先放一边，好帮她寻找她最喜欢的薯片。哦，我们对此会有很多话要说。这是一个非常奇怪的题外话，我可不是故意把话题引向一个超级诡异的方向。说吧。珍娜，当我在重温这一集时，我听到我旁边有骚动，那就是她说的。不。然后一只松鼠正在吃一只小鸟。这比
what I thought you were going to say. Yeah, and so I was like, wait, what's he eating? What's he eating? I start filming it. I have video of me filming the squirrel, and in the background, you can hear grief counseling in a bird funeral. Oh my God. It was so crazy. But apparently squirrels are like, they're like an opportunist, you know? If there's a little bird's nest, they go for a baby bird, they do it. Squirrels are terrible. Everyone thinks they're so cute because of their fluffy tails, but they're awful. Look it up, everybody. Squirrels carry more disease than rats. Look it up. Okay, sorry, but it just was kind of crazy that I was watching an episode that had a bird funeral, and then I saw a squirrel
我想象的还要糟糕。是的，当时我就想，等等，它在吃什么？它在吃什么？我开始拍视频。我有自己拍松鼠的视频，而在背景音里，你能听到悲伤辅导和小鸟葬礼的声音。天哪。太疯狂了。但显然松鼠就像是那种机会主义者，你知道的？如果有小鸟巢，它们就会去抓小鸟宝宝，它们真的会这么做。松鼠太可怕了。每个人因为它们毛茸茸的尾巴觉得它们很可爱，但它们其实很讨厌。大家去查查吧。松鼠携带的病毒比老鼠还多。去查查吧。好吧，抱歉，只是刚好看到我正在看的一集里有小鸟葬礼，然后我就目睹了一只松鼠
attack a bird. It was crazy. Yeah. Okay, how do we get back from that? Hit me with some fast facts. All right, fast fact number one. This episode was written by Jen Solato. We said that, and Angela reached out to Jen for this episode. Yes, Jen and I traded emails and texts, and she was so much fun to talk to about this episode. She was so excited to share information. And so she sent in a whole bunch of audio clips that we are going to play, and she is going to come back as a full, awesome guest for maybe two episodes coming up, Jenna. Ooh. Ooh, we're trying to figure out scheduling and whatnot, but she is in and I cannot wait. Well, let's play her hello audio clip, Sam. Okay. Hey, guys,
攻击小鸟，这实在太疯狂了。是的。好吧，我们怎么把话题拉回来？快来点快讯吧。好的，快讯一。这一集是由珍·萨拉达编剧的。我们说过这个，安吉拉为了这一集还特意联系了珍。是的，我和珍互发了电子邮件和短信，跟她聊起这一集真的超级开心。她特别高兴能分享这些信息。所以她发来了一大堆音频片段，我们一会儿会播放，而且珍娜，她接下来甚至可能会作为全期嘉宾回归，录制未来的一两集节目呢。哦。哦，我们正在敲定档期之类的，但她已经答应了，我简直迫不及待。好吧，萨姆，我们来播放她的问候音频吧。好的。嘿，伙计们，
it's Jen. I miss you. I'm loving your podcast. I am learning so much. I had no idea of the drama behind the scenes of Booze Cruise, where you were floating away at Sea Angela with Phyllis and Rain and Brian. Amazing. Anyway, I'm loving it, and I'm going to answer some grief counseling questions. So I'll send them in separate audio files. Isn't it nice to hear her voice, Ange? I love her voice. I find her voice really soothing. Now, listen, we were chatting back and forth, and I was listening to her voice a lot. And Jen, I think you have real good podcast voice. I know. Jen, are you doing voiceover work? Like, I'd buy anything you're selling with your voice. Or just call me and talk to me at the end
我是珍。我想念你们。我超爱你们的播客。我学到了好多。我以前根本不知道《乘风破浪》背后还有那么多幕后戏剧，当时你安吉拉跟菲利斯、雷恩还有布莱恩一起在海上漂流。太神奇了。不管怎样，我很喜欢这个节目，而且我要回答一些关于悲伤辅导的问题。所以我把它们放在单独的音频文件里发过去。听到她的声音真好，对吧，安吉？我超爱她的声音。我觉得她的声音特别舒缓。现在听着，我们之前一直在聊天，我听了她很多语音。珍，我觉得你真的有一副很好的播客嗓音。我知道。珍，你在做配音工作吗？比如，不管你用这声音卖什么我都买。或者干脆每天在我
of my day. Just leave me a message every day. Just kind of telling me what you did. Yeah. Because I will listen to that as I like do the dishes. I agree. And Angela, in one of the clips that Jen sent, she explains a little bit about the process of writing this episode for her, right? Yeah, it's so, it's so fascinating. Sam, can you play it? Enjoy Jen's voice, everyone. One thing about this episode that really stuck with me personally was it was a thrill because it was hard to tell stories on other shows about characters going through internal things. And in this case with Michael, it was even more than that because this character was going through something internal and he was unaware of it, which made it really exciting
下班的时候给我打电话跟我聊聊天。每天给我留个言就行。就随便讲讲你那天都干了什么。对。因为我一边洗碗就会一边听这个。我完全同意。安吉拉，在珍发来的其中一段音频里，她稍微解释了一下自己创作这一集的过程，对吧？是的，真的太迷人了。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？大家一起来欣赏珍的声音吧。关于这一集，有一点深深印在我个人的脑海里，那就是它非常刺激，因为在其他剧集里很难去讲述角色经历内心挣扎的故事。而在迈克尔的这个案例中，甚至远不止于此，因为这个角色正在经历某种内心的波澜，而他自己却浑然不知，这让创作过程变得异常兴奋，
to write because I love internal stories, but it also made it kind of difficult to explain at times. And I remember that I created a little chart where it said, here's what Michael is doing and saying in the scene. And then in bold under it, I wrote what was actually happening to Michael underneath it all. And of course, Steve got it all intuitively and he's a genius. It was such a treat to be able to write and tell that kind of story. And then Jenna, to have you be aware of what it was that was going on with Michael, to have Pam sort of sense it and see it and fix it without it being spoken was just such a delight as a writer. Isn't that amazing? I love it. I love that she had like a secret notes and
因为我喜欢内心的故事，但这也让它有时很难解释清楚。我记得我曾制作过一张小图表，上面写着：迈克尔在这一幕中正在做什么和说什么。然后在下面用粗体写着：迈克尔在这一切表象之下实际正在经历什么。当然，史蒂夫凭借直觉完全理解了，他是个天才。能够编写和讲述这样一种故事，简直是一种享受。然后珍娜，你能意识到迈克尔身上到底发生了什么，让帕姆在没有明说的情况下能够某种程度上感知到它、看到它并去弥补它，作为编剧，这简直太美妙了。这难道不神奇吗？我太喜欢了。我喜欢她在剧本里为角色的情感旅程写了秘密笔记和
charts in her script about the emotional journey of characters. Yeah, I find all that so interesting, just like the writer's process and what she wrote and how then it ended up playing, you know? Oh my gosh, Angela, I just realized something. What? She was tracking. She was tracking Michael's emotional journey. She tracked it. All right. Well, we are going to hear more from Jen throughout the episode. So Jenna, why don't you fast fact me? Okay, I'm calling fast fact number two, the big fight. Oh, you did a shoulder shimmy. I know. Are you intrigued? I am. In Mindy Kaling's book is everyone hanging out without me. She writes a chapter about working on the office and being a writer and also being a performer. And she said in her book
图表。是的，我发现所有这些都太有趣了，无论是编剧的过程、她写了什么，还是最终呈现出来的效果，你知道的？天哪，安吉拉，我刚刚意识到一件事。什么？她在追踪。她在追踪迈克尔的情感旅程。她追踪了。好吧。接下来我们在整集中还会听到更多来自珍的内容。所以珍娜，快给我来个快讯吧。好的，我宣布快讯二，大吵一架。哦，你还耸了耸肩膀。我知道。你感兴趣吗？我很感兴趣。在敏迪·卡灵的书《大家都在没有我的地方闲逛吗？》中，她写了一章关于在《办公室》工作、既是编剧又是演员的经历。她在书里提到，
that she and Greg Daniels got into such a huge fight during this episode that she stormed off the set. She kicked his car. Yes. Oh, that's so good. I forgot about that. But rather than have me read you the passage, Angela, wouldn't you rather hear it in Mindy's voice? Yes. Well, guess what? What? There's an audio book. Oh, oh my god. Oh my god. Hit play, Sam. I want to hear it. All right. Here is the clip from the audio book of is everyone hanging out without me and other concerns. It's published by Penguin Random House LLC and read by Mindy Kaling. I tend to fight with Greg the most. My friend and fellow office writer Steve Healy believes it is because I am emotional and intuitive and Greg is more cerebral and logical.
她和格雷格·丹尼尔斯在这一集拍摄期间大吵了一架，以至于她气冲冲地离开了片场。她还踢了他的车。哦，太棒了。我都把这事儿忘了。不过，与其让我读给你听，安吉拉，你难道不想听听敏迪自己的声音吗？想听。好吧，你猜怎么着？什么？有有声书。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。萨姆，快播放。我想听。好的。以下是《大家都在没有我的地方闲逛吗？及其他困扰》的有声书片段。由企鹅兰登书屋有限责任公司出版，由敏迪·卡灵朗读。我往往跟格雷格吵得最凶。我的朋友兼《办公室》同行编剧史蒂夫·希利认为，这是因为我比较感性、直觉敏锐，而格雷格则更理性和逻辑化。
Or as I like to think of it, I am a sensitive poet and Greg is a mean robot. Our fighting is legendary. One time late at night, our script coordinator Sean and our head writer Danny both brought in their dogs and upon seeing each other, they got into a violent barking fight. Paul Lieberstein glanced over and joked, Oh, I thought that was just Greg and Mindy. What do we fight about? I wish I could say they were big, smart philosophical issues about writing or comedy. But sometimes they're as small as if we do that cold open where Kevin dumps a terrine of chili on himself. I will quit the show. We did that cold open by the way, and it was a hit. And I'm still working at the show. I can get a little theatrical,
或者按照我自己的理解，我是一个敏感的诗人，而格雷格是一个冷酷的机器人。我们吵架的事迹可是传奇级别的。有一次深夜，我们的剧本统筹肖恩和我们的首席编剧丹尼都把各自的狗带到了办公室，它们一见面就爆发了一场激烈的狂吠对骂。保罗·利伯斯坦瞥了一眼，开玩笑道：“哦，我还以为那是格雷格和敏迪呢。”我们在吵什么呢？我真希望我能说那是一些关于写作或喜剧的高深宏大的哲学问题。但有时它们小到就像：如果我们拍那个冷场开场白——凯文把自己弄得满身都是一盆辣椒，我就要辞职不干了。顺便说一句，我们确实拍了那个冷场开场白，而且大获成功。我到现在还在这部剧里工作呢。我有时候会有点戏剧化，
which makes sense because after all, I came up through the theater, said in my snootiest masterpiece theater voice. I will tell you about the worst fight we ever had. In a very heated rewrite session for the season three episode grief counseling, I was arguing with Greg so much he finally said in front of all 12 writers. If you're going to resist what I'm doing here, you can just go home Mindy. Greg never sends anyone home or even hints at it. Greg is the kind of guy who is so agreeable. I frequently find him on our studio a lot embroiled in some long, boring conversation with a random person while his lunch is getting cold in his to go container. And he's a boss. I would never talk to anyone
这也说得通，毕竟我是从戏剧界出来的——我用最装腔作势的“名作剧场”语气说道。我要跟你们讲讲我们经历过的最惨烈的一次争吵。在第三季“悲伤辅导”那一集一次气氛非常热烈的重写剧本会议上，我和格雷格吵得不可开交，他终于在所有12位编剧面前脱口而出：“敏迪，如果你非要抗拒我在这里做的改动，那你现在就可以回家了。”格雷格从不轻易让任何人回家，甚至连暗示都没有。格雷格就是那种极其好说话的人。我经常发现他在我们片场的某个角落跟一个陌生人进行着漫长而无聊的对话，而他的午餐在打包盒里都快凉透了。而且他还是个老板。如果我是老板，我才不会跟任何人说话呢。
if I was the boss. I would only talk to my attorney and my psychic. So anyway, my very nice boss had just hugely reprimanded me. Greg suggesting I go home unless I adjusted my attitude was the harshest he'd ever been to anyone in three years I'd been on the show. There was silence. No one looked at me. People pretended to be absorbed in their phones. One writer didn't even have a phone he just pretended to be absorbed in his hand. I was so embarrassed and angry that I got up stomped out of the room, stole a 24 pack of bottled water from the production office, kicked the bumper of Greg's car and left the studio. Is that amazing? It's amazing. I love the detail that she took a 24 pack of water. Oh,
我只会跟我的律师和心理医生交流。总之，我这位非常好的老板刚刚狠狠地训斥了我。格雷格让我“如果不调整态度就回家”这句话，是我在这部剧工作的三年里听过的最严厉的话。现场一片死寂。没有人看着我。大家假装全神贯注地看着手机。有个编剧甚至连手机都没有，他就假装全神贯注地看着自己的手。我当时又尴尬又生气，于是我站起身，气冲冲地走出房间，从制片办公室顺走了一箱24瓶装的矿泉水，狠狠踢了格雷格汽车的保险杠，然后离开了片场。这难道不惊人吗？太惊人了。我好喜欢她顺走一箱24瓶水的这个细节。哦，
yeah. Oh, I'm leaving. I am leaving. But I'm going to be hydrated. Well, listen, she goes on to say that after this, she went to a nail salon to get a pedicure. And the woman asked her, oh, do you have the day off? And Mindy was like, no, my boss threw me out of work. And the woman was like, oh, you got fired. And that's when Mindy was like, oh, wait, wait, what am I doing here? And she drove back to work and she told everyone she'd been in the bathroom. But Angela, she did keep that water. Good for you, Mindy. Her book is so fantastic. I own this book. It is hilarious. It is a great read. Mindy, thank you so much for letting us use a little excerpt from it and you have to come on the show.
对啊。哦，我要走了。我要离开这里了。但我得保证水合作用。好吧，听着，她接着说，在这之后，她去了一家美甲店做修脚。美甲师问她：“哦，你今天放假吗？”敏迪回答说：“没有，我老板把我从工作岗位上赶出来了。”美甲师说：“哦，你被解雇了。”就在那时，敏迪心想：“等等，等等，我在这里干什么？”于是她开车回到了公司，并告诉所有人她刚才一直在洗手间。不过，安吉拉，她确实把那些水留下了。干得漂亮，敏迪。她的书太精彩了。我买过这本书。太爆笑了。绝对值得一读。敏迪，非常感谢你让我们引用书中的一小段内容，你必须得来我们的节目做客。
And she is, guys, because I texted her and she's coming on. She's coming on. We won't say when, but it's happening. It's soon. You guys, if you're looking for entertainment right now, give it a try. The audiobook is available on the Penguin House audio website and SoundCloud.com. And thank you to Penguin Random House for letting us play the clip. I love knowing that this was going on in the backdrop of us filming this episode. You're kicking a car. You're taking water. Jen Salata is on set cracking up. What is happening in the writer's room? Should we move on to Fast Fact number three? I mean, I don't know how you beat one and two, but go for it. Well, I'm not sure I will, but I got a little scoop
她会的，伙计们，因为我给她发了短信，她马上就要来了。她要来做客了。我们先不说具体什么时候，但这件事一定会发生。就在不久的将来。大家伙儿，如果你们现在想找点乐子，一定要去听听。有声书可以在企鹅兰登书屋的有声读物网站和SoundCloud.com上找到。感谢企鹅兰登书屋允许我们播放这段剪辑。一想到在我们拍摄这一集的背景里正在发生这些事，我就觉得太有意思了。你踢了一辆车。你顺走了水。珍·萨拉达在片场笑得前俯后仰。编剧室里到底在发生些什么啊？我们要不要进入快讯三？我是不知道你们怎么超越第一条和第二条啦，但尽管试试吧。
from Kentopedia about this episode. Ooh. All right. On the first shoot day of this episode, it reminded me that we had our big season three photo shoot for NBC where we did a big cast photo shoot. We did individual photos all in character. And since there weren't a lot of scenes happening in the break room, that's what we use for the photo shoot. I don't know if you remember it, Angela. I do. They set up a desk and then they would switch out the props on the desk and we would take single photos. And I have this very stern single photo of me holding a pencil and a pad of paper with a drawing on it that I have never felt properly represents the character of Pam because I think I look like a teacher
好吧，我不确定能不能超越，但我从小肯百科（Kentopedia）那里打听到了一些关于这一集的独家猛料。哦。好的。在这一集的第一个拍摄日，这让我想起了我们当时为NBC拍摄的第三季大型宣传照，我们在那里拍了一组合照。我们拍了所有角色的单人照。由于休息室里没有太多戏要拍，我们就把那里当成了拍照的场地。我不知道你还记不记得，安吉拉。我记得。他们摆了一张桌子，然后不断替换桌上的道具，我们就轮流拍单人照。我有一张非常严肃的单人照，手里拿着一支铅笔和一个带有涂鸦的记事本，我一直觉得这张照片根本无法代表帕姆这个角色，因为我觉得在这张照片里我看起来像个随时准备训斥你的老师，
who's ready to scold you in this photo as opposed to a woman going through a life-altering journey of love and expression. I have a photo of me looking very stern and sort of a severe ponytail and I'm holding up a card with a cat on it. Well, then they took the desks away and they loaded the break room with paper boxes and we all posed in front of them. Do you remember that one? I do because it was actually a very small space. And when they got us all in there, they then couldn't figure out how to get us all in the photo. We were so jam-packed. So they had tiered these boxes like a little pyramid and guess who had to crawl up to the tippity top and is at the very top. And really, I just look like a very
而不是一个正在经历颠覆人生的爱与自我表达之旅的女性。我有一张照片，看起来非常严肃，梳着一丝不苟的高马尾，手里举着一张画有猫咪的卡片。好吧，后来他们把桌子搬走了，在休息室里堆满了纸箱，我们所有人都在纸箱前摆姿势。你还记得那次吗？我记得，因为那个地方其实非常小。等把我们所有人都塞进去之后，他们却开始发愁怎么把所有人都拍进照片里。我们实在挤得太满了。所以他们把这些纸箱像小金字塔一样层层叠叠地堆起来，你猜是谁不得不爬到最顶端，最后站在了最高处？说实话，在照片的最边缘，我看起来真的就像一颗
tiny floating head in the way back of the photo. It's me. Well, then they moved us all over to the warehouse. Do you remember this? And they made rain paper on us. They blew paper in a giant fan. This was a little insane because it took, I mean, I can't even remember how many times to blow the paper. Yeah, I have a great photo from this day. I don't know who took it actually, but it's in between whenever they blew the paper in the air, then they'd have to stop and reset it. Yeah, they'd have to pick up all the paper from the ground. Yeah. And then someone would have to bring it back and toss it back in the air, right? So it was like a 20 minute turnaround between these setups. And in between the setups, we
漂浮在远处的微小人头。那就是我。好吧，后来他们把我们转移到了仓库。你还记得这个吗？他们让雷恩往我们身上吹纸。他们用一台巨大的风扇吹纸。这简直有点疯狂，因为这花了好长时间，天哪，我都记不清拍了多少次才把纸吹好。是的，我有一张那天拍的超级棒的照片。我其实不知道是谁拍的，但就在他们把纸吹到空中、不得不停下来重新摆设的间隙。对，他们必须把地上的所有纸都捡起来。对。然后得有人把它们拿回来重新扔到空中，对吧？所以每次布景之间大概需要20分钟的周转时间。而在这些布景的间隙，我们
all had to just stay there in the warehouse. We're like on the loading dock area, right? Yeah. And I'm in my skirt and my blouse, my severe ponytail. And I squat down, lady like in a skirt, you know how you can tuck your skirt up in your leg and squat down so you're not ruining the mystery for anyone. Sure. I said, sure, like you weren't sure. I squat down in my Angela Martin outfit to talk to Paul Lieberstein. So there's this great photo of everyone sort of milling about in between this paper setup. And I'm squatting down so completely out of character talking to Paul. I love it. Well, it was really crazy because we would have to shoot these whole episodes, but then
所有人就只能待在仓库里。我们大概在卸货平台附近，对吧？对。我穿着我的半身裙和衬衫，梳着一丝不苟的高马尾。我蹲了下来，像个淑女一样穿着裙子——你知道那种你可以把裙子塞进腿底下然后蹲下来、这样就不会在任何人面前走光的方法吗？当然。我说了“当然”，就好像你不太确定似的。我穿着安吉拉·马丁的行头蹲下来跟保罗·利伯斯坦聊天。所以有一张非常棒的照片，记录了大家在这次纸箱布景的间隙四处闲逛的情景。而我正蹲在那里，完全脱离了角色地跟保罗聊天。我太喜欢了。好吧，这真的很疯狂，因为我们不仅要拍完整集的戏，而且每当他们布置新场景时，
also like when they would be setting up a new scene, we would run off to the warehouse and take pictures with the paper coming down on us. Yeah. It was a bizarre day. It was super, it was super bizarre. And when Kent wrote me and reminded me of that, it all kind of came flooding back. Like, oh, yeah. Remember how weird that was? Yeah. Well, listen, should we take a break and then get into this episode? Let's do it. Let's do it. All right, we'll be right back. All right, so we're back. We are in the bullpen. That's what we would call the big main room where, you know, Michael would always come out and talk to everyone. And he is doing
我们还得跑去仓库，顶格拍摄纸片从我们身上落下来的画面。是的。那是怪异的一天。超级超级怪异。当肯特写信提醒我这件事时，记忆一下子全涌上心头。就像，哦，对啊。还记得当时有多诡异吗？是的。好吧，听着，我们要不要先休息一下，然后正式进入这一集？开始吧。开始吧。好的，我们回来了。我们现在在开放式办公区。那是我们对那个主大厅的称呼，迈克尔总是会从那里出来跟所有人说话。而他现在
a bit guys. He has got a bit. He has stacked up some boxes of paper. Jenna, now that I remember that we were doing the photo shoot, I feel like those were the boxes that were in the break room that we took pictures on. I'm not even kidding. They very may well have been so Michael's doing that classic like stairs or escalator bit, you know, where you stack up a bunch of stuff and then you slowly just kind of crouch down and Dwight thinks it is the funniest thing he's ever seen. Oh, Reign's reaction is like if you showed that to a five year old. Yeah. Yeah. Butter glee and just this is the best joke he's ever seen. Ever seen. It is. And also he's laughing as if he's never heard of it.
在整蛊大家。他有个恶作剧。他堆了好几箱纸。珍娜，现在我想起我们在拍宣传照的事，我觉得那些就是我们在休息室里拍照时用的箱子。我真的一点都没开玩笑。完全有可能就是那些箱子，所以迈克尔在玩那个经典的“假楼梯”或“自动扶梯”的恶作剧，你知道的，就是你堆了一堆东西然后慢慢蹲下去，德 Dwight（德怀特）觉得这是他见过的最好笑的事。哦，雷恩的反应就像你把这事儿展示给一个五岁小孩看一样。是的。充满喜悦，而且觉得这是他见过的最棒的笑话。有史以来最好笑的。确实是。而且他笑得好像从来没听说过这玩意儿似的。
Yes, this is all new to him. He made it. He made it to be an adult man and has never seen the fake stairs bit. But, you know, I think, you know, in this episode, Pam is a little bit of the gym. Pam has taken on the jokester role, right? Yeah. So Ryan and Kevin joined in. They asked him to get little things like a pen, you know, but then Pam shown a little bit of Pam's ass is like, how about a cup of coffee? How about you give me a cup of coffee? And Michael's like, Well, I have a lot to say about this cold open edge. Oh, I want to hear it. First of all, this was not the original cold open in the script. Somebody has the original script. I've got a shooting draft of grief counseling.
是的，这一切对他来说都是崭新的。他活到成年居然从来没见过假楼梯的恶作剧。但是，你知道的，我觉得在这一集中，帕姆有点成了吉姆。帕姆承担起了恶作剧制造者的角色，对吧？是的，所以雷恩和凯文也加入了。他们让他去拿一些小东西，比如一支笔，你知道的，但接着帕姆展现了她“帕姆式”的一面，说道：“来杯咖啡怎么样？你给我倒杯咖啡怎么样？”然后迈克尔说……关于这个冷场开场白，我有太多话想说了，安吉。哦，我好想听。首先，这并不是剧本里的原始冷场开场白。有人拥有原始剧本。我有一份《悲伤辅导》的拍摄版剧本。
Let's hear it. The original cold open was in Stamford. And it involved, yeah, and it involved a coworker of Jim wanting him to look at photos of her baby. Oh, oh, I saw this in a deleted scene. And she gets really put out with him because she shows him a picture of her husband and the baby in the bathtub. And Jim is like, finds it off pudding. He's like, Oh, God, they're in the bathtub. And she's like, Oh, you know what? Come back to me when you have kids, okay? Like she gets really mad at them. Well, this was the original cold open. This cold open was added later. And we shot it at the end of the week because it was an ad. And we had all those boxes. We had all those boxes from our photo shoot.
我们听听看。原版的冷场开场白发生在斯坦福。内容涉及——是的，涉及吉姆的一个同事想让他看她宝宝的照片。哦，哦，我在删减片段里看过这个。她对吉姆很不满，因为她给吉姆看了一张她丈夫和宝宝在浴缸里的照片。然后吉姆觉得有点倒胃口。他心想：“天哪，他们在浴缸里。”然后她说：“哦，你知道吗？等你有了孩子再来跟我谈吧，好吗？”就像她对吉姆非常生气一样。好吧，这才是原版的冷场开场白。这个冷场开场白是后来加进来的。而且我们在周末快结束时才拍的，因为它是个加拍镜头。我们当时有那些箱子。我们有拍照时留下的所有箱子。
Oh my gosh. I wonder if they were inspired. They were like, Wait, I know what we can do with these boxes just stacked in the middle of the soundstage. We got it. Yeah. A lot of people wrote in and said, Oh my gosh, how many takes did you guys do of this cold open? Because if you notice, Steve looks like he's like sweating when he brings him her coffee. He is sweating his butt off. He is so tired. Kent told me we did 10 take 10 times. And every time we did a take, Steve went up and down the stairs three times. Oh my God. So he did that 30 times. He was getting like a major like one of those like your quads says the person who never works out. What are those called? Your quads. He was getting
天哪。我在想他们是不是灵感突发。他们当时想：“等等，我知道我们能用这些堆在摄影棚中央的箱子干嘛了。我们有主意了。”是的。很多人写信来问：“天哪，这个冷场开场白你们到底拍了多少条？”因为如果你注意看的话，史蒂夫给他端咖啡的时候看起来像是在疯狂出汗。他汗流浃背。他累坏了。肯特告诉我我们拍了10条。而且每拍一条，史蒂夫就要上下楼梯三次。天哪。所以他总共做了30次。他的股四头肌肯定得到了极大的锻炼——一个从不健身的人如是说。那些叫什么来着？你的股四头肌。他当时在锻炼
like, there's probably some quad and glue, quad and glue. And then he had to crawl around any one or poor guy. And Kent also told me that we actually did six different camera setups for the scene because they had to move the camera in different places to do the shot when he's crawling, when he goes inside the kitchen for his talking head, which is technically part of it. So yeah, but he he walked up and down the stairs 30 times. Oh my gosh, Steve, your butt. Yeah, it's been so sore. Well, I have two two little things in this opening scene. First of all, at 51 seconds, I think Angela kind of smiles. Oh, when Pam says get a cup of coffee, Angela kind of has a smile. Like there is a brief moment where I think
股四头肌和臀大肌。然后他还得在地上爬来爬去，可怜的家伙。肯特还告诉我，我们实际上为这个场景设置了六个不同的机位，因为当他爬行时以及当他走进厨房进行单人访谈（这也是其中的一部分）时，他们必须把摄像机移动到不同的地方来完成拍摄。所以，是的，他上下楼梯走了30次。天哪，史蒂夫，你的屁股一定酸痛极了。好吧，我在这个开场场景里有两个小细节要分享。首先，在51秒的时候，我觉得安吉拉好像笑了。哦，当帕姆说“来杯咖啡”时，安吉拉脸上泛起了一丝微笑。好像有那么短暂的一瞬间，我觉得
she's on your side. I just wanted that to be documented. Oh, and then I have a great fan catch at one minute, 27 seconds. Ready for this? Yeah. Kelly and Chloe Harrigan and Shannon Rajowski, they wrote in and they noticed that when Michael returns from the kitchen when he's crawling on the ground, that that is Jim's coffee mug. That's the coffee mug that Jim always uses. Oh my gosh, yes. Isn't that a great catch? And I was like, I wonder if that was a little nod to Jim so that Jim's presence got to be in Scranton for a little moment. I love that. Great catch, guys. Great catch. All right, so then we move into Michael's office and he's on the phone with Jan, who informs him that they have lost Ed Truck.
她站在你这边。我只是想把这个记录下来。哦，然后我在1分27秒处有一个超棒的粉丝捕捉点。准备好了吗？是的。凯莉、克洛伊·哈里根和香农·拉霍斯基写信提到，他们注意到当迈克尔从厨房返回、在地上爬行时，他拿的是吉姆的咖啡杯。那是吉姆总是用的那个咖啡杯。天哪，没错。这难道不是一个绝佳的发现吗？当时我就想，不知道这算不算对吉姆的一个小致敬，让吉姆的存在感也能在斯克兰顿短暂地出现一下。我太喜欢了。发现得太棒了，伙计们。太棒了。好吧，接下来我们来到迈克尔的办公室，他正在跟简通电话，简通知他埃德·特拉克去世了。
And then Michael's like, well, I have his number somewhere. I can find it for you. Yeah. And she's like, no, Michael, Ed Truck has died. He goes out into the room. He breaks the news to everybody. Kelly rushes up, gives him a hug. Oh, we have a special appearance by Kelly's extensions and her bangs. They make a special appearance. They are hugging Michael, giving him some comfort. And then Michael approaches Pam for a little awkward hug. So awkward. And lady, I have a track moment. I'm tracking it. I'm tracking. What are you tracking? You know, I love to track the plants at front reception. Are there more new plants? Well, whatever happens to them, they make an appearance and then we never see them again.
然后迈克尔说：“好吧，我某个地方有他的电话号码。我可以帮你找找。”是的。而简则说：“不，迈克尔，埃德·特拉克已经去世了。”他走到外面的大办公室。把这个消息告诉了所有人。凯莉冲过来，给了他一个拥抱。哦，凯莉的接发和刘海在这里作了特别客串。它们闪亮登场了。它们拥抱着迈克尔，给予他一些安慰。然后迈克尔走向帕姆，想要一个有点尴尬的拥抱。超级尴尬。各位，我有了一个“植物追踪”时刻。我在追踪。你在追踪什么？你知道我很喜欢追踪前台的植物。又有新的植物了吗？不管它们后来怎么了，它们总会露面一次，然后我们就再也见不到它们了。
At three minutes, 29 seconds, I am pretty sure that's a succulent. We have a succulent succulent alert, succulent alert at front reception. We'll probably never see it again. But when Michael hugs Pam awkwardly, you get a nice shot of that succulent. I'm not kidding. I really need to start a spreadsheet. A really complex spreadsheet. All the things we're tracking. Well, next we move over to the Stanford office and a staff meeting becomes very awkward when Josh is super sexist and condescending to Karen. Oh, he was. He's sort of just totally dismissed her. I know. Yeah. Seriously. And then he puts Jim in charge of her for the day. Oh, gross. Oh my gosh. This is like a physical representation of mansplaining,
在3分29秒的时候，我非常确定那是一株多肉植物。我们迎来了多肉植物警报，前台的多肉植物警报。我们可能以后再也见不到它了。但当迈克尔尴尬地拥抱帕姆时，镜头给那个多肉植物来了一个非常棒的特写。我真的没开玩笑。我真的得建个电子表格了。一个超级复杂的电子表格。记录我们追踪的所有东西。好吧，接下来我们转移到斯坦福办公室，由于乔什对卡伦表现得极其大男子主义且居高临下，一场员工会议变得异常尴尬。哦，他确实如此。他简直就是完全不把她放在眼里。我知道。是的，太严重了。然后他让吉姆负责监督她一天的工作。哦，太恶心了。天哪。
I feel like. Yeah. You know what? Jim, why don't you check in on that? Yeah, why don't you oversee that, Jim? Why don't you check in on that? And she's like, yeah, thanks. Yeah, thanks. Yeah, thanks. Well, we had a fan catch from Brandon. He says at three minutes and 42 seconds when Karen is flipping through her stack of papers. I think I see a page from the script in her notes. Oh, oh, that's a good catch. You do. I froze it. Oh, yeah. She's got a little script page. We used to do that. Remember, and we used to hide script pages in our notebooks. I used to keep them in a drawer like in between takes. I would open my drawer and I would be like, okay, wait, did I get it? Did I get it to get it?
我觉得这简直就是“爹味说教”的实体化表现。是的。你知道吗，吉姆，你去跟进一下那个项目吧？是的，吉姆，你为什么不监督一下那个呢？你去跟进一下吧。然后她说：“好，谢谢。”“对，谢谢。”“好，谢谢。”好吧，我们收到了来自布兰登的粉丝捕捉。他说在3分42秒时，当卡伦翻阅厚厚的一叠文件时。我好像在她的笔记里看到了剧本的一页。哦，哦，这个发现真不错。确实看到了。我把画面定格了。哦，是的。她夹了一小页剧本。我们以前也这么干过。记得吗，我们以前经常把剧本页藏在笔记本里。我以前会把它们放在抽屉里，比如在拍片间隙。我会拉开抽屉心想：好的，等等，我记住了吗？我有记住台词吗？
And then I shut my drawer again. Yes, we had scripts hidden everywhere on that set that we could just peek at between scenes to make sure we were like on our lines or if we wanted to like prep right before. I mean, obviously we had worked on them and we knew our lines, but when you're doing a bunch of takes, sometimes you're like, oh, wait, crap, what was that? And you just want to do a quick peek. But also, you know, they would have their writer's draft and then we would read it at a table read and then they would make a bunch of changes and they would start on Monday with what was called the shooting draft. And that's what I have. I have a bunch of shooting drafts left over. But every single morning we would
然后我再把抽屉关上。是的，我们在那个片场到处都藏了剧本，这样我们在两场戏的间隙就可以偷看一眼，确保我们的台词没有出错，或者在开拍前临时复习一下。当然，我们事先都做过功课，台词也都背熟了，但当你拍了很多条时，有时你会想：“哦，等等，糟了，那句台词是什么来着？”然后你只想快速偷看一眼。而且，你知道的，他们会有编剧初稿，然后我们会在围读会上读剧本，接着他们会做出大量的修改，并在周一带着被称为“拍摄版剧本”的剧本开工。我手上就有很多这样的剧本。我留下了好几份拍摄版剧本。但每天早上我们
arrive to work and there would be a stack of new pages. They were rewritten scenes just for that day. They would hand you the pages sometimes that morning and be like, okay, here we go, guys. These are your changes for the day. You better believe we were hiding pages in our desks and notebooks. But yes, Brandon, you saw one. That just tickled me because that is so true. That was a good catch. Okay, so now at four minutes, two seconds, Karen is really disappointed, you guys, because the chips that she likes, they're not in the vending machine. But I think Jim felt bad
到达片场时，都会有一叠新页。那些是专为当天拍摄重写的场景。他们有时会在那天早上把剧本页交给你，然后说：“好了，伙计们，我们开始吧。这些是你们今天的修改内容。”你绝对可以相信我们在办公桌和笔记本里藏了剧本。不过，是的，布兰登，你确实发现了一页。这真的让我忍俊不禁，因为太真实了。这个发现太棒了。好了，现在在4分02秒，卡伦非常失望，伙计们，因为她喜欢的薯片在自动售货机里买不到。但我认为吉姆觉得
at the way Josh treated her and he now wants to make amends, right? He wants to try to help her find these potato chips. And this whole scene about Karen and her potato chips just got me thinking about Rashida's breakfast order. Okay, do you remember her breakfast order? No. Okay, well, we often were in hair and makeup together at the same time. And I texted her because I was like, Rashida, I totally just had this memory of your breakfast order. Here was the great thing about our caterer, Sergio. First of all, he was amazing. But if your
乔什对待她的态度很过分，他现在想做出弥补，对吧？他想试着帮她找到这种薯片。而关于卡伦和她的薯片的这场戏，让我想起了拉什达（Rashida）的早餐订单。好吧，你还记得她的早餐订单吗？不记得。好吧，我们俩以前经常同时在化妆间化装。我给她发了短信，因为我说：“拉什达，我刚才突然想起了你的早餐订单。”我们的餐饮承包商塞尔吉奥（Sergio）最棒的一点在于。首先，他太棒了。但如果你的
order became kind of popular, if other people liked it, you would get your name on the menu. Yes. Because you would walk up to the truck to order breakfast in the morning, the food truck, and you could order a Rashida Angela size, because I always wanted everything half portion, because it was just big. The portions were big and I'm a little person. So I'd always say, can I have half of that? So they started calling it Angela size. So here's what the Rashida was. And Sergio, I ran into Sergio a while back because I was working on a Netflix show and he was the caterer for it. For Mindy's show, never have I ever. He was the caterer.
点单变得挺受欢迎，如果其他人也喜欢，你的名字就能登上菜单。是的。因为你早上可以走到餐车去点早餐，那个餐车，你可以点“拉什达-安吉拉”份量，因为我总是想要所有东西都只要半份，因为分量太大了。分量真的很大，而我是个小个子。所以我总是说：“能给我半份吗？”于是他们开始把这叫作“安吉拉份”。所以拉什达的订单是这样的。而塞尔吉奥——我前不久偶遇了塞尔吉奥，因为我在参与制作一部网飞剧集，他是那部剧的餐饮承包商。为了敏迪的剧《好想做一次》，他是餐饮承包商。
Yeah, Mindy hired him, which was fantastic. We had a little mini office reunion. And here's the Rashida, which you can still order from Sergio. Ready? Yes. A corn tortilla, poached egg, black beans, avocado, turkey bacon, chalula on the side. And I was texting with Rashida about it and she was like, I don't even know how I functioned after eating that. Like, why should I have just gone and taken a nap? But that's called the Rashida. But I can get that Angela size if I'm not that hungry.
是的，敏迪雇了他，这太棒了。我们举行了一个小型办公室重聚。这就是“拉什达”套餐，你现在依然可以从塞尔吉奥那里点到。准备好了吗？是的。玉米饼、水波蛋、黑豆、牛油果、火鸡培根，旁边配上夏洛特辣酱（Cholula）。我当时还跟拉什达发短信聊起这个，她当时就说：“我真不知道我吃完那个是怎么正常运转的。比如，我当时难道不应该直接去睡个午觉吗？”这个就叫“拉什达”套餐。但如果我没那么饿，我可以点“拉什达-安吉拉”份。
Yeah, I'd like the Rashida Angela size, please. Oh, my gosh, that brought back so many memories. Molly Neck wrote in to say, guys, you can see her favorite chips in the vending machine, slot B1. Okay, so there's a row of potato chips in the vending machine, but apparently those aren't the ones that Karen wants. Yes, Karen wants salt and vinegar potato chips. I did a mini deep dive on hers potato chips. And Philadelphia magazine did a ranking of all the hers potato chips and salt and vinegar
好吧，请给我来一份“拉什达-安吉拉”份，谢谢。哦，天哪，这勾起了我太多的回忆。莫莉·内克（Molly Neck）写信说：“伙计们，你们可以在自动售货机的B1槽里看到她最喜欢的薯片。”好吧，自动售货机里确实有一排薯片，但显然那些不是卡伦想要的那种。是的，卡伦想要的是盐醋味薯片。我对她喜欢的薯片做了一次微型深度挖掘。费城杂志对所有的赫尔斯（Herr's）薯片进行了一个排名，而盐醋味
was their number one chip. So it might make sense that it was hard to find because it's the number one chip. Close behind was cheddar horseradish. Pam's favorite sour cream and onion was number four. Our favorite is their barbecue chips. I love their hers barbecue chips. I don't know where that is in the ranking. On the ranking. Okay. I'm sorry, I didn't look that one up.
排在了他们所有薯片的第一位。所以很难找到它也是情理之中，因为它可是排名第一的薯片。紧随其后的是切达辣根味。帕姆最爱的酸奶油洋葱味排在第四位。我们最喜欢的是他们的烧烤味薯片。我超爱他们的赫尔斯烧烤味薯片。我不知道这个在排名里排第几。在排名上。好吧。抱歉，那个我没有去查。
Okay. But I do have a script catch for you as well. We're not done talking about this yet. In the shooting draft of the script, her favorite chips were going to be salsa verde doritos. Wow. So here we go. We're going back to Scranton and Creed is in Michael's office with Dwight and Michael. And he tells them that Ed was decapitated. And Michael's like, what? And he goes, yeah. He was flying down the road. He'd been drinking. And I guess he ran into a semi truck, right? And was decapitated.
不过我也有一个剧本细节要分享给你们。我们还没聊完这个呢。在剧本的拍摄版中，她最喜欢的薯片原本是“青椒莎莎多里托斯”（Salsa Verde Doritos）。哇。好了，我们回到斯克兰顿。克里德和德怀特、迈克尔一起在迈克尔的办公室里。他告诉他们埃德被斩首了。迈克尔说：“什么？”他说：“对啊。他开车在路上飞驰。他喝了酒。我猜他撞上了一辆半挂货车，对吧？然后被斩首了。”
Yeah. Angela, we got a lot of mail about this scene with Creed. Okay. There is a very, very big debate online over whether or not Creed the character is making it up that Ed was decapitated or if it's the truth. The truth within the show. And you know, Creed told some crazy stories, both on camera and off camera. So I can see where this sort of like controversy, if you will, around Creed's retelling of this. Is it true? Is it not? Fiona, Danielle, Kelly, Danny, Mackenzie, Adam, and Valerie. They all said, how did Creed
是的，安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于克里德这场戏的邮件。好吧。网上有一个非常非常激烈的争论，关于克里德这个角色到底是捏造了埃德被斩首的事，还是确有其事。剧集内部的真相。你知道的，克里德在镜头前和镜头后都说过一些离谱的故事，所以我能理解为什么围绕着克里德对这件事的复述会产生这种争议。这是真的吗？还是假的？菲奥娜、丹妮尔、凯莉、丹尼、麦肯齐、亚当和瓦莱丽。他们都说，如果迈克尔是从总公司得知消息的第一人，克里德怎么会知道埃德·特拉克之死的具体细节呢？所以他们的理论是克里德在胡编乱造，因为他绝对不可能比迈克尔知道更多细节。然后玛丽亚指出，克里德后来在另一集中撒谎说德怀特被斩首了。
know the details of Ed Truck's death if Michael was the first to know from corporate? So their theory is that Creed's making it up because there's no possible way for him to know more details than Michael. And then Maria pointed out that Creed lies later in another episode and says that Dwight was decapitated. That's in the episode, the return. So she's like, maybe Creed is just obsessed with decapitation because he's a weird character. I don't know. Well, here's the thing. I love that you guys were all writing back and forth about this. I think that because Creed knew Ed, he actually knew Ed, maybe there was someone he called. But we decided, hey, let's go to the source. Let's ask Jen Salada, was this story made
那是在《回归》那一集里。所以她说，也许克里德只是对斩首有着某种痴迷，因为他是个古怪的角色。我不知道。不过事情是这样的。我很高兴你们大家一直在为此写信讨论。我觉得因为克里德认识埃德，他确实认识埃德，也许他有认识的人可以打电话。不过我们决定：嘿，不如直接去找消息源。我们去问问珍·萨拉达，这个故事到底是克里德这个角色捏造的，还是剧集设定中的真相？这真的发生过吗？所以珍是这么说的。埃德·特拉克真的被斩首了吗？对于埃德·特拉克来说，不幸的是，他确实真的被斩首了。这听起来像是一个克里德式的故事，但它在我们的剧集世界里其实是一个真实的故事。没有埃德·特拉克这个人，他也没有真的失去脑袋。然而，在《办公室》的世界里，他确实实实在在地被斩首了。我想是格雷格想出了斩首这个点子。我记不太清了，格雷格也记不清了。但我记得我们花了很长时间讨论迈克尔的前老板会以什么样的方式死去，而且必须是那种非常突然、
up by Creed the character or was it truth in the sort of scope of the show? Did this really happen? So here's what Jen had to say. Did Ed Truck really get decapitated? Sadly for Ed Truck, he did really get decapitated. It sounds like a Creed story, but it actually was a true story in the world of our show. There's no Ed Truck and he didn't really lose his head. However, in the world of the office, he did get decapitated for real. I think it was Greg that came up with the decapitation. I can't quite remember and Greg can't remember. But I remember spending a lot of time talking about the way Michael's former boss would die and how it had to be something very sudden
令人震惊的方式，这样才能对迈克尔·斯科特的精神世界造成冲击，让他某天突然彻底抓狂，因为他原本只是过着自己的日常生活，去办公室上班，然后突然之间人就没了。所以我觉得斩首这个桥段就是这么来的。不幸的是，我也记不清到底是谁想出了“从脑袋上被斩首”这个词。我觉得应该不是我，因为如果是我，我当时一定会引以为傲，而且我肯定会记住的。不过，是的，对于埃德·特拉克来说，斩首这件事在设定里是真的。对不起了，埃德·特拉克。真相就是这样。埃德·特拉克真的被斩首了。克里德确实掌握了一些迈克尔都不知道的细节。
and jarring so that it could be a shock to Michael Scott's system that he could just freak out one day because he's just living his life and going into the office and then all of a sudden he could be dead. So I think that is where the decapitation came from. Unfortunately, I also can't remember who came up with his cappas detated from his head. I feel like it wasn't me because I would have been really proud of it if it was me and I'd remember that. But yeah, the decapitation was real for Ed Truck. Sorry, Ed Truck. There you have it. Ed Truck really got decapitated. Creed actually got some facts that Michael didn't know.
这就是克里德那滑向未知的灰色地带，我得告诉你们，无论是现实生活中还是作为这个角色，他有时候会说出一些话，你会想：“这绝对不是真的。”然后结果发现它是100%真的。接着他又会说些别的，结果完全是一派胡言。是的。欢迎来到克里德的世界。确实如此。好吧，在这之后，迈克尔决定把这个消息告诉整个办公室。我太喜欢那个对白了。我真的超爱，我反复看了好几遍迈克尔说“我不知道该怎么告诉你们这件事”。然后德怀特接着说：“埃德·特拉克被斩首了。”
This is the slippery slope with Creed and let me tell you, this is true in real life and as this character, he'll say something and you're like, that's not true. And then it's 100% true. And then he'll say something else and it's total BS. Yes. Welcome to the world of Creed. That is true. Well, after this, Michael decides to break the news to the whole office. I love the little couplet. I just loved it. I watched it over and over of Michael being like, I don't know how to tell you this. And then Dwight is like, Ed Truck was decapitated.
迈克尔说：“你在这儿干什么呢？”他说：“你说你不知道该怎么说啊。你说你不知道该怎么说。”德怀特太死心眼了，对吧？太死心眼了。天哪。这也把我笑得不行。好吧，各位，我想聊聊这场戏里的一个细节，因为在5分38秒时，我记下了“安吉拉的表情”。他们怎么了？
And Michael's like, what are you doing? He's like, you said you didn't know how to say it. You said you didn't know how to say it. Dwight is so literal, right? So literal. Oh my God. It made me laugh so hard too. Well, lady, I want to talk about something in this scene because at 5 minutes, 38 seconds, I wrote down Angela's face. What'd they do?
我觉得在那一刻，你做出了一个我心目中堪称“典型安吉拉式”的反应。你在我们的剧里做出过那么多嫌弃的表情，我觉得它们太搞笑了，因为我在现实生活中从来没见你做出过这种表情。这些表情一点都不符合你的个性，但它们都被做成表情包了。你就是以这种不赞同的眼神而闻名。但这对我来说很有趣，因为在现实生活中，你一点都不是这样的人。人们写信来说：“哦，你总是挂着一张‘生无可恋脸’（resting bitch face）。”你听过这个词吧？是的。
I feel like in this moment, you have what I would consider to be a quintessential Angela reaction. You made so many sour faces on our show and they are so funny to me because I never see you make these faces in real life. They are so not your personality, but they have been turned into memes. You are known for this just disapproving look. But it's just funny to me because in real life, you are nothing like this. People write in and say, oh, you have resting bitch face. You've heard that expression, right? Yeah.
我觉得此时此刻，你有了一种我认为可以说是极具安吉拉特点的反应。你在我们的节目中做出了那么多酸楚的表情，我觉得它们太搞笑了，因为我从未在现实生活中看到你做出这些表情。它们一点也不符合你的性格，但它们已经被做成了表情包。你以这种不赞成的表情而闻名。但这对我来说很有趣，因为在现实生活中，你一点也不是这样。人们写信来说，哦，你有一副生气的面孔。你听说过这个词，对吧？是的。
RBF. But now they're just calling it resting Angela Martin face. It's like resting Angela face. I know. But this is cracking me up right now in a whole different way because I am doing this show called Be Our Chef. I'm hosting this family cooking competition. Lady, you know I know this. We watch it. We watch it religiously. Thank you. My kids love this show. You guys, it's a cooking show. It's on Disney Plus. You have to watch
RBF。不过现在他们都管它叫“安吉拉·马丁面无表情”。就像“安吉拉面无表情”一样。我知道。但这现在以一种完全不同的方式让我笑死，因为我正在做一个叫《来当主厨吧》（Be Our Chef）的节目。我是这个家庭烹饪比赛的主持人。天哪，你知道我知道这个。我们在看。我们雷打不动地看。谢谢。我的孩子们很喜欢这个节目。各位，这是一个烹饪节目。在迪士尼+（Disney Plus）上播出的。你们得看
it. It's families cooking and competing. Angela's the host and it is just the sweetest, most uplifting, most just pure fun. Oh, that is so sweet. Here's the thing my family's doing. You're saying that you froze on my face making the sour face? Yeah. My family keeps doing like freezing the screen when I'm making the weirdest faces. I guess in Be Our Chef, I have learned that I talk really animated and I move my hands around and it's like I'm Jim Carrey.
它。这是一个家庭烹饪和比赛的节目。安吉拉是主持人，它真的超级温馨、超级治愈、纯粹充满乐趣。哦，这太贴心了。我家人在做的是这样的。你说你在我做苦瓜脸的时候截屏了？对。我家人总是趁我做出最奇怪的表情时把画面暂停并截屏。我想我在《来当主厨吧》里，已经了解到我说话时表情非常丰富，而且手舞足蹈的，就像金·凯瑞（Jim Carrey）一样。
My kids think I look crazy most of the time on Be Our Chef and their favorite thing now is to screen grab it and text me. I'm loving it. And Angela, I have to say this last Friday when it came on, I was like, guys, we're going to watch Be Our Chef and Angela's on and my daughter goes, you really love Angela. Aw. She is your best friend. And I said she is my best friend. Aw, that is so sweet.
我的孩子们觉得我在《来当主厨吧》里大部分时间看起来都很疯狂，他们现在最喜欢的事就是截屏然后发短信给我。我太喜欢了。而且安吉拉，我不得不说，上周五节目播出的时候，我对他们说，伙计们，我们要看《来当主厨吧》，安吉拉在里面，然后我女儿就说，你真的很喜欢安吉拉。哇。她是你最好的朋友。我说她确实是我最好的朋友。哇，这太暖心了。
I know. That is so sweet. I know. Okay, so yes, I make weird faces everybody. I make weird faces. While we're talking about my weird faces, Jenna, in the scene, Ward White asked Angela to put his head on ice, right? Oh, yes. Five minutes, 44 seconds. Right at the top of the scene, I'm getting something out of
我知道。这太暖心了。我知道。好吧，所以没错，我做鬼脸，大家都知道。我做鬼脸。在我们聊我的鬼脸的时候，詹娜，在那个场景里，沃德·怀特（Ward White）让安吉拉把他的头放在冰上，对吧？哦，是的。5分44秒。就在那个场景开头，我正在从
the vending machine. Did you notice my jacket? Yeah, lady, I have the same time code. Five minutes, 44 seconds, I wrote, Angela Wardrobe, what's up? I know. What is up with your very odd, short-sleeved jacket? What is this item? It is a short, it's a, it's a, can it be purchased or was this made for you? Now, I think someone purchased it or found it in a warehouse like NBC, but it is a short-sleeved pinstriped, kind of like a dress jacket. And I jokingly called it to Wardrobe, my Janet
自动售货机里拿东西。你注意到我的夹克了吗？对，天哪，我有相同的时间代码。5分44秒，我写道，安吉拉的戏服，这是什么情况？我知道。你那件非常奇怪的短袖夹克是怎么回事？这到底是什么单品？这是一件短袖，它是一个，一个，它可以买到还是专门为你做的？现在，我想有人买的，或者是在像NBC这样的仓库里找到的，但它是一件短袖细条纹的，有点像连衣裙的夹克。我开玩笑地管它叫服装组的珍妮特·
Jackson jacket, because do you remember, I loved Janet Jackson. And do you remember Rhythm Nation, her album Rhythm Nation? Yeah. Okay, watch the music video of the song, All Right. She is wearing this pinstriped jacket. Of course, mine was short-sleeved, hers was like regular, but we jokingly called this to the Wardrobe Department, my Janet Jackson jacket. It is? I don't know. It was so weird. It was weird. It was, it was like short-sleeve, but it
杰克逊（Janet Jackson）夹克，因为你还记得吗，我超爱珍妮特·杰克逊。你还记得《节奏国度》（Rhythm Nation）吗，她的专辑《节奏国度》？对。好吧，去看那首歌《一切都好》（All Right）的音乐录影带。她就穿着这件细条纹夹克。当然，我的是短袖，她的就像正常款，但我们在服装部门开玩笑地管这个叫我的珍妮特·杰克逊夹克。是吗？我不知道。太奇怪了。太奇怪了。它，它就像是短袖的，但它
was a jacket. I'm sorry to whoever designed it, but it's like your short-sleeve blouse is peeking out underneath your short-sleeve jacket. It's an odd design. It's a total mess. It's a total mess, but it makes, it makes me laugh to look back on it. I think a little bit reminds me of something that you might see on Project Runway when they had to like make a jacket out of another jacket, like they had to like re-imagine the jacket.
是一件夹克。对不起设计它的那位，但它看起来就像你的短袖衬衫从你的短袖夹克下面露出来了一样。这是一个奇怪的设计。简直是一团糟。简直是一团糟，但回想起来让我觉得很好笑。我觉得它有点让我想起你在《天桥骄子》（Project Runway）里可能会看到的那种设计，当时他们必须用另一件夹克来做一件夹克，就像他们必须重新构思这件夹克一样。
Re-imagine the jacket, and they just made it a short-sleeve jacket, and they were voted off. Yeah, pretty much. All right, guys. So then we have a pretty adorable Dwight Talking Head where he says that he wants to be frozen when he dies, even if they have to do it in pieces, even if he has decapitated, he wants to be frozen because he will wake up stronger than ever, and he will have been able to use that time to figure out how he died and how he could have better defended himself.
重新构思这件夹克，然后他们就把它做成了一件短袖夹克，然后他们就被投淘汰了。对，差不多吧。好吧，伙计们。接下来我们有一个非常可爱的德怀特（Dwight）独白镜头，他说他死后想要被冷冻，哪怕他们得把他切成碎片冷冻，哪怕他被斩首了，他也想要被冷冻，因为他醒来时会比以往任何时候都更强壮，而且他将能够利用这段时间弄清楚他是怎么死的，以及他如何能更好地保护自己。
Yeah. Yeah, he's thought it through. He's thought it through. I love talking heads. Angela does not want to participate in this. She doesn't want to. No. No. So now Michael is on the phone with Jan, and he really doesn't understand why they have a day honoring Martin Luther King when he didn't even work at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. But Ed Truck, Ed Truck sat at his same desk and has died, and Jan's like, okay, listen,
对。对，他都想好了。他都想过这事了。我喜欢独白镜头。安吉拉不想参与这个。她不想。不。不。所以现在迈克尔（Michael）正在和简（Jan）通电话，他真的不明白为什么他们会有一个纪念马丁·路德·金（Martin Luther King）的日子，而他甚至都没在邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）工作过。对。但是埃德·特拉克（Ed Truck），埃德·特拉克坐过他同一张办公桌，而且已经去世了，简就说，好吧，听着，
do you want to just give everyone the day off? And he's like, you don't get these people. They wouldn't want that. No, they don't want to go home. What they want is a robot statue of Ed Truck. The eyes light up. Yeah. That's what they want. Well, we had a fan question here from Sierra. When Michael is on the phone with Jan and has an article with a picture of himself and Ed on the desk in front of him, he slowly
你想直接给大家放一天假吗？然后他说，你不了解这些人。他们才不想要那个。不，他们才不想回家。他们想要的是一个埃德·特拉克的机器人雕像。眼睛会发光。对。那就是他们想要的。好吧，这里有一位粉丝西拉（Sierra）的提问。当迈克尔和简通电话，面前的桌子上放着一张有他和埃德照片的文章时，他慢慢地
drags the corner of an envelope down to cover Ed's head, you know, because he's been decapitated. Was that scripted? Yes. That action was scripted. It was in the script. And then, of course, you see the camera made sure to capture it. So smart. So smart. So thought out. Well, I really thought Dwight's drawing of the robot with the six foot extension cord to the wall so it couldn't attack him. I thought that was fantastic. And I wanted to know who drew it, but we probably don't know, do we?
用信封的一角往下拖，遮住埃德的头，你知道的，因为他被斩首了。那是剧本里写的吗？是的。那个动作是剧本里写的。然后，当然，你可以看到摄像机确保捕捉到了这一幕。太聪明了。太聪明了。太周到了。嗯，我真的很喜欢德怀特画的那个带有六英尺延长线连到墙上以免机器人攻击他的机器人画。我觉得这太棒了。我想知道是谁画的，但我们可能不知道，对吧？
We don't know. We had fan questions about that too, and I tried to find out, but I couldn't get the answer for you. I'm sorry. That's all right. I think it was rain. I don't think it was rain. I drew it in the back just quickly on a notepad. I'm sure. But I feel, I feel like I can say with 99% certainty it was not rain. I feel like rain might have doodled on it during the scene, but the original drawing
我们不知道。我们也有关于这个的粉丝提问，我试图查清楚，但我没能为你找到答案。对不起。没关系。我觉得那是雷恩（Rainn）画的。我觉得不是雷恩画的。我在后面随手在一个记事本上快速画的。我确信。但我觉得，我觉得我可以有99%的把握说那不是雷恩画的。我觉得雷恩可能在拍摄那场戏时在上面涂鸦过，但最初的画
was not rain. Yes. Okay. Now we have to go back over to Stanford. I actually texted Ed Helms. I said, Ed, you just made me do the snort laugh so hard because here we are. Jim and Karen are still trying to find these chips. They're having a hard time, but Jim's like, we're not going to quit. And she's like, I'm not a quitter. And then Andy's like, what, what's the game? What are we playing? I'm in. And they tell them we can't find the chips. And he's like, did you check the vending machine?
绝对不是雷恩画的。好的。现在我们得回到斯坦福（Stanford）分公司了。我真的给埃德·“海尔姆斯”（Ed Helms）发了短信。我说，埃德，你刚刚让我大声笑出了猪叫，因为我们在这里。吉姆（Jim）和凯伦（Karen）还在努力找那些薯片。他们遇到了困难，但吉姆说，我们不会放弃的。然后她说，我不是个轻言放弃的人。然后安迪（Andy）说，什么，什么游戏？我们在玩什么？算我一个。然后他们告诉他我们找不到薯片。然后他说，你们检查过自动售货机了吗？
And they're like, oh, no, actually we checked the fax machine. And you see how pissed off Andy gets at them because he knows, he knows they're being smart asses. And he just looks at them so seriously and goes, did you check your butt? He turns around. It made me laugh so loud. It made me laugh so hard. I like watched it twice back to back. So I was like, oh my God. And then I texted Ed. I said, Ed, you are so funny in the scene. I texted him the line and he was like, we were like trading texts about it, just cracking up.
然后他们说，哦，不，其实我们检查了传真机。你可以看到安迪对他们有多生气，因为他知道，他知道他们在耍小聪明。他一脸严肃地看着他们说，你们检查过你们的屁股吗？他转过身去。这把我笑得太大声了。这把我笑得太惨了。我连续看了两遍。因为我想，哦，天哪。然后我给埃德发了短信。我说，埃德，你在这场戏里太搞笑了。我把那句台词发短信给他，然后他回复说——我们就这句台词发短信交流，笑得前仰后合。
Well, that line is in the script. I went and looked. I had to know. But I don't know if you noticed in this scene, seven minutes, 35 seconds, the smile post it is gone from Jim's computer. You've been tracking that post it lady. I've been tracking it. All right. And I don't know if you notice, I mean, he's acting more like Jim now, right? Like he's got a little thing. He's dazzling a lady with his charm. He took he's getting more
嗯，那句台词是在剧本里的。我去查了。我必须知道。但我不知道你有没有发现在这场戏里，7分35秒的时候，吉姆电脑上的那个“微笑”便签不见了。你一直在追踪那个便签，天哪。我一直在追踪它。好吧。而且我不知道你有没有注意到，我的意思是，他现在的行为更像吉姆了，对吧？就像他有点小动作了。他用他的魅力让一位女士眼花缭乱。他开始变得更
comfortable. Yeah, he's more comfortable and he has an adventure within work, right? That's kind of like, this is a boring job to Jim. So he always has to find a distraction to get him through the day. Jim's the guy who makes work more fun, right? With his little things like this that he does. So he's back to his old ways. Back at the Scranton branch, Michael is just obsessed now. He just can't stop thinking about Ed Truck. And he's really starting to internalize it about himself, right? Like
自在了。是的，他更自在了，而且他在工作中有了一场冒险，对吧？这有点像，这对吉姆来说是一份无聊的工作。所以他总是必须找到一个能让他度过这一天的消遣。吉姆就是那种让工作更有趣的人，对吧？通过他做的这些小事情。所以他又回到了老路上。回到斯克兰顿（Scranton）分公司，迈克尔现在简直着了魔。他脑子里一直想着埃德·特拉克。而且他真的开始把这件事代入到自己身上了，对吧？比如，
what if I were gone? No one cares here. No one cares. And he decides that they probably need some grief counseling. They're in denial. Yeah. Yeah, he wants us to know the stages of grief. And he feels like it's his job to take us through them. He doesn't know if he can get us all the way to acceptance, but if he can get us depressed, he will have done his job. It's such a great line.
如果我不在了呢？这里根本没人会在乎。没人会在乎。于是他决定他们可能需要一些心理辅导。他们处于否认期。对。是的，他想让我们知道悲伤的几个阶段。他觉得带我们经历这些是他的职责。他不知道自己能不能把我们完全带到接受的阶段，但如果他能让我们感到沮丧，那他就完成任务了。这台词太棒了。
It's such a good line. I have a really great little tidbit right here. What is it? Okay, so in the deleted scenes, Toby is actually a trained grief counselor. Okay. Yes. And so Dwight's like, Toby should probably lead us through this. He's a trained grief counselor. And Toby starts to walk them through the steps. They're in the conference room. And Michael's like, oh, you're ruining everything. It's going to take me forever to undo what
这台词太好了。我这里有一个非常棒的小花絮。是什么？好吧，所以在被删减的片段中，托比（Toby）其实是一个受过专业训练的悲伤辅导员。哦，对。是的。所以德怀特就说，托比大概应该带我们度过这个阶段。他是一个受过专业训练的悲伤辅导员。然后托比开始带他们经历这些步骤。他们在会议室里。迈克尔就说，哦，你把一切都搞砸了。我要花好久才能撤销你
you've done. And of course, Toby was being perfectly normal and appropriate, right? Yes. Michael's like, you're ruining it. And this whole scene is in the conference room taking place around the conference table. Everyone's sitting there. And Michael's like, that's it. I'm going to have to fix everything you've ruined, Toby. Ryan, Dwight, take the conference table out. We're going to take a five minute break while they reset. And we're coming back in here and I'm going to lead you in grief counseling.
做过的事。而且，当然，托比表现得完全正常且得体，对吧？是的。迈克尔就像是在说，你把它全毁了。整个场景都发生在会议室的会议桌周围。每个人都坐在那儿。迈克尔就说，够了。我得把你弄砸的一切都修好，托比。瑞安（Ryan），德怀特，把会议桌搬出去。我们要休息五分钟，等他们重新布置好。我们要回到这里，由我来带领你们进行悲伤辅导。
And I about fell out of my chair because in my knowledge, that is the first time we have ever referenced the dang conference table. Oh, my gosh. And now we know who's always moving it. It's Dwight and Ryan Dwight and Ryan where they put it. I don't know, but we don't know. It was the first time I ever heard Michael say, okay, let's get the conference table out of here. Yes. Acknowledging that the conference table can be removed and replaced on a whim. How do they get it out of the doorway? I don't know. They probably have to take it apart. But Michael's like, we're going to
我差点从椅子上摔下来，因为据我所知，这是我们第一次提到那张该死的会议桌！哦，天哪。现在我们知道是谁总是在搬它了。是德怀特和瑞安，德怀特和瑞安把它们搬到哪儿去了？我不知道，但我们不知道。这是我第一次听到迈克尔说，好吧，把会议桌搬出去。是的。承认会议桌可以随时被搬走和替换。他们是怎么把它搬过门口的？我不知道。他们可能得把它拆开。但迈克尔说，我们要
take five to 10 minute break. And when we get back in here, we're going to get down to it. And then the next scene is them with the little ball that they're about to toss around. But that's a deleted scene that sets it up. I love that. I love that. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we will meet Michael in the conference room for some, some of his grief counseling. Yeah. And maybe sound good. Maybe Roy will stop by. Who knows? He might cause Pam might need a little break as well. All right, we'll be right back.
休息5到10分钟，当我们回到这里时，我们要开始干正事了。然后下一个场景就是他们拿着那个准备传来传去的球。但这设定这一切的是一个被删减的片段。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后等我们回来，我们将在会议室里迎接迈克尔，进行一些他的悲伤辅导。对。也许，听起来不错？也许罗伊（Roy）会顺便过来。谁知道呢。他可能会来，因为帕姆（Pam）可能也需要休息一会儿。好吧，我们马上回来。
And we're back. Here we are. Angela, what did you do during the break? I went and got an iced tea, Jenna, and I said hi to my husband. And I walked up, I guess behind him kind of quietly and I scared the crap out of him. Oh, that's what I did on my break. I was like, hey, he was like, why does it get me so tickled? I like, I don't know why spooking him makes me laugh so hard. I got a cup of coffee and then I put the sheets from the washer into the dryer. And I'm all excited that I'm podcasting and doing the laundry at the same time because you know I love a good multitasking. Oh, yeah. Oh, I have laundry going, lady.
我们回来了。我们在这儿。安吉拉，你在休息的时候做了什么？我去拿了一杯冰茶，詹娜，我还跟我老公打了招呼。我走过去，我想我是悄悄走到他身后，然后把他吓了个半死。哦，我在休息时就做了这个。我就像，嘿，他当时就说，为什么这总是能逗乐我？我就像，我不知道为什么吓他会让我笑得这么厉害。我泡了一杯咖啡，然后把洗衣机里的床单放进了烘干机里。我很高兴我能一边录播客一边洗衣服，因为你知道我喜欢多任务处理。哦，对。哦，我有衣服正在洗呢，天哪。
I started in the morning. Oh, it's going. It's also, I find that when I do laundry, I can't podcast in my closet because you can hear the dryer. So on the days I do laundry, I podcast in my shed. There you go. There you go. Making it work. Podcasting from home. I'm in my pajamas. I never said that at the beginning. Oh, I noticed. I didn't say anything, but I noticed. I did my hair though. I don't know what that says about me when my hair is done. I feel good even if I'm still in my pajamas. There you go. All right, guys, we are back in the conference room and Michael is going to lead us in some
我早上就开始洗了。哦，正在洗呢。而且，我发现当我洗衣服时，我不能在我的衣帽间里录播客，因为你能听到烘干机发出的声音。所以在我洗衣服的日子里，我在我的棚子里录播客。就是这样。就是这样。让它顺利进行。在家录播客。我穿着睡衣。我一开始没说这个。哦，我注意到了。我什么也没说，但我注意到了。不过我弄了头发。当我的头发弄好了，这不知道说明了我什么。我感觉很好，哪怕我还在穿睡衣。就是这样。好吧，伙计们，我们回到了会议室，迈克尔将带领我们进行一些
grief exercises. It involves taking a ball and when you have the ball, you can talk about a moment of grief in your life. Michael goes first. Yeah, of course. Michael goes first and he talks about Ed Truck. Angela, when he says his feelings about Ed Truck, it's so good. He goes on and on. I asked Sam to pull a clip so that we could all listen to it together. Oh God, I'm so happy about this because I wrote in my journal that in this scene, this particular moment, we could not get through. And lady, it's not in the script. This was, I think, an improvisation by Steve. Oh my God. Okay, well, there's one line. I'm not going to say it yet. Let's listen to it. There's one line
悲伤练习。这涉及拿一个球，当你拿着球时，你可以谈论你生活中的一个悲伤时刻。迈克尔先来。对，当然。迈克尔先来，他谈论了埃德·特拉克。安吉拉，当他说出他对埃德·特拉克的感受时，太棒了。他滔滔不绝。我请萨姆（Sam）剪辑了一个片段，这样我们就可以一起听了。哦天哪，我太高兴了，因为我在日记里写了，在这一幕中，这个特定的时刻，我们根本无法坚持下去。而且，天哪，这不在剧本里。这我认为是史蒂夫（Steve）即兴发挥的。哦天哪。好吧，有一句台词。我先不说。我们听听看。有一句台词
that I wrote in my journal. We all disintegrated. So, oh my God, wait, hold on. What is it, baby? Sonny got a bird. Oh, okay, hold on. I'll be right back. Okay. He got one of the doves. Yeah. And what's happening? Got a bird. Sonny is their cat. So here's the thing. This podcast started with me telling about a squirrel that ate a bird, and now their cat just got a bird. I'm telling you, this is the bird funeral podcast. Okay, okay. I'm so sorry. I'm back. What happened? What happened? You guys, we got a grocery delivery and Sonny shot out the door and I guess caught a bird, right? This is so insane that we're doing this episode right now. And
我写在了日记里。我们全都笑崩了。所以，哦天哪，等等，等一下。怎么了，宝贝？桑尼（Sonny）抓到了一只鸟。哦，好吧，等一下。我马上回来。好的。他抓到了一只鸽子。对。发生什么事了？抓到了一只鸟。桑尼是他们的猫。所以事情是这样的，这个播客开始于我讲述一只松鼠吃了一只鸟，现在他们的猫刚刚抓到了一只鸟。我跟你说，这是鸟类葬礼播客。好吧，好吧。非常抱歉。我回来了。发生什么事了？发生什么事了？各位，我们收到了一个杂货配送，桑尼冲出了门，我想他抓到了一只鸟，对吧？我们现在正在录制这一集，发生这种事简直太疯狂了。而且
Angela, you had a squirrel eating your bird when you were prepping. I had a squirrel eating a bird. Now your cat has, like, attacked a bird. Okay, but listen, it's good news. I have good news. We caught Sonny. We wrestled him to the ground. We got the bird out of his mouth and it's a pretty big bird and he was unharmed. The bird was unharmed. You saved the bird. The bird's okay. Michael would be so happy. What's going to happen next week for the initiation? I don't know. I don't know. I don't want to be initiated, Jenna. No. I don't want it. Oh, please.
安吉拉，你准备节目时也有一只松鼠在吃你的鸟。我有一只松鼠在吃鸟。现在你的猫又，像，袭击了一只鸟。好吧，但是听着，有好消息。我有好消息。我们抓住了桑尼。我们把他按倒在地上。我们从他嘴里把鸟掏出来，这是一只挺大的鸟，而且它毫发无损。这只鸟毫发无损。你救了这只鸟。这只鸟没事。迈克尔会太高兴了。下周的入会仪式会发生什么？我不知道。我不知道。我才不想加入什么组织，詹娜。不。我才不要。哦，拜托。
Don't bring that over here. I don't want any of that. Okay. All right. Well, that was crazy and so sorry. I can't believe this is all happening in grief counseling, but let's, okay, where were we? All right. Let's play this clip of Michael talking about his grief of Edtrak. I lost Edtrak and it feels like somebody took my heart and dropped it into a bucket of boiling tears. And at the same time, somebody else is hitting my soul in the crotch with a frozen sledgehammer. And then a third guy walks in and starts punching me in the grief bone. And I'm crying and nobody can hear me because I am terribly, terribly, terribly alone.
别把那个拿到这儿来。我才不要那些呢。好吧。好吧，那太疯狂了，非常抱歉。我不敢相信这一切都发生在悲伤辅导中，但是好吧，我们说到哪儿了？好吧。让我们播放这段迈克尔谈论他对埃德·特拉克的悲伤的片段。我失去了埃德·特拉克，感觉就像有人掏出我的心，把它扔进了一桶沸腾的眼泪里。与此同时，另一个人正在用一柄冰冻的大锤猛击我灵魂的胯部。然后第三个人走进来，开始痛击我的悲伤骨。我在哭，却没人能听到，因为我真的，真的，真的太孤独了。
Angela, can I guess the line that we couldn't get through? Yeah. Is it frozen sledgehammer? I put every one of us broke when he said that his soul was getting hit in the crotch with a frozen sledgehammer. Yes. That's what I wrote in my journal. I said we could not keep it together. Okay. I said that's not in the script. I don't know if he was handed that rewrite on the day, but it feels like that's a Steve. That's a Steve improv. That feels like Steve to me. Oh, man, man, man. That got us good though. Oh, man. That is so good. Well then Roy walks in. There's a problem with Pam's car. Can she come down to the parking
安吉拉，我能猜出我们演不下去的那句台词吗？行啊。是“冰冻的大锤”吗？我敢说我们每个人在听到他说他的灵魂被用一柄冰冻的大锤猛击胯部时都破防了。对。这就是我在日记里写的。我说我们根本控制不住自己。好吧。我说那不在剧本里。我不知道那是当场给他的改写台词，但感觉那是史蒂夫的风格。那是史蒂夫的即兴发挥。这感觉太史蒂夫了。哦，天哪，天哪，天哪。不过那句话把我们整惨了。哦，天哪。这太棒了。然后罗伊走了进来。帕姆的车出了点问题。她能去停车场
lot and take a look at it? Oh, yeah. So there is an extended scene of this in the deleted scenes. So if you thought it was awkward enough, their conversation by the car, there's it's extended and even more awkward. Jenna, here's my question for you. How did Roy know that she was stuck in the conference room? How? How did he know there was grief counseling? How? Oh, okay. I think you're implying that she called Roy and told him about it. I'm just saying, how did he know? How did he know? Okay, I have a take on it. I think Michael called Daryl down in the warehouse and said, bring everyone up for some grief counseling. And Daryl was like, no, no. Well, that that would
看看怎么回事吗？哦，对。所以在被删减的片段中，有一个关于这个的加长场景。所以如果你觉得他们在车旁的对话已经够尴尬了，那是加长版的，甚至更尴尬。詹娜，我有个问题要问你。罗伊怎么知道她被困在会议室里的？怎么知道的？他怎么知道有悲伤辅导的？怎么知道的？哦，好吧。我想你的意思是她打电话给罗伊并把这事告诉了他。我只是在想，他是怎么知道的？他是怎么知道的？好吧，我有一种看法。我觉得迈克尔给仓库里的达里尔（Daryl）打了电话，说把大家都叫上来做点悲伤辅导。然后达里尔说，不，不。好吧，那就能解释通了。
explain it. Yes, that would explain it. We had a fan question from Alexa Porter. Was there ever talk of putting Pam and Roy back together or was it all just a setup to mess with our feelings? Well, there was talk in the writer's room that maybe Roy could win Pam back. Remember, David Denman was made a series regular for season three. Yeah. So he's going to be making a lot of appearances this season. I can tell you guys nothing was decided at this point about what would happen with Jim and Pam, what would happen with Pam and Roy? They were feeling it out week to week. I totally remember that. I also remember it was constantly said that maybe, maybe in the series of the office, Jim and Pam would
是的，那就解释得通了。我们有一个来自亚历克斯·波特（Alexa Porter）的粉丝提问。有没有讨论过让帕姆和罗伊复合，还是这纯粹是一个为了搞砸我们感情的设定？嗯，编剧室里确实讨论过罗伊也许能重新赢得帕姆的芳心。记住，大卫·丹曼（David Denman）在第三季中成为了常规演员。是的。所以他这一季会有很多出场。我可以告诉大家，在这个时间点，对于吉姆和帕姆会怎么样，帕姆和罗伊会怎么样，还没有做出任何决定。他们是周复一周地在摸索。我完全记得那个。我也记得当时经常有人说，也许，也许在《办公室》这个剧集里，吉姆和帕姆
not end up together in the end, but would instead lead one another to their actual true loves. There was, it had not been decided right now that Jim and Pam were one another's true loves. When you just said that, I got angry. Oh, no. I was like, no, Jim and Pam end up together. No. Well, I think maybe that's why the writing of their characters felt so authentic because the writers were figuring out their relationship at the same time that Jim and Pam were. Yeah. So we're, as an audience, we feel that like, what will happen? We don't know. These are two people on journeys trying to find themselves. And hopefully that leads them back to each other. Exactly. All right. So while Pam and Roy are out in the parking
最后不会在一起，而是会引导彼此去寻找他们真正的真爱。曾经有过，当时还没有决定吉姆和帕姆就是彼此的真爱。当你刚才这么说的时候，我生气了。哦，不。我当时想，不，吉姆和帕姆最后必须在一起。不。好吧，我想这也许就是为什么他们角色的剧本感觉如此真实，因为编剧们在摸索他们的关系的同时，吉姆和帕姆也在摸索。所以我们作为观众，会有那种感觉——接下来会发生什么？我们不知道。这两个人都在寻找自我的旅程中。希望这能引领他们回到彼此身边。完全正确。好吧，所以当帕姆和罗伊在停车场时，
lot, I'm sure Pam was really hoping that she's going to come back to the like conference room and the grief counseling is almost over. But no, they waited for her because they're a family. I love that detail. They waited for her. Yes. There's a great scene on the DVD. It's a deleted scene. And Michael is trying to get everyone to loosen up, right? For the grief counseling. He's like, Hey, guys, take your jackets off, loosen your ties, take off your shoes. Ladies, let your hair down. And Angela goes, I don't think Kevin should take off his shoes. Oh, and Kevin gets really annoyed. And then he has a talking head that he says, All right, listen, I have hyper hydrosis. Okay. So we find out that he has this disease
我确信帕姆真的很希望她回到会议室时，悲伤辅导快要结束了。但并没有，他们一直在等她，因为他们是一家人。我喜欢这个细节。他们一直在等她。是的。DVD上有一个很棒的场景。那是一个被删减的场景。迈克尔正试图让每个人都放松下来，对吧？为了悲伤辅导。他说，嘿，伙计们，脱掉夹克，松开领带，脱掉鞋子。女士们，把头发放下来。然后安吉拉说，我觉得凯文不应该脱鞋。哦，凯文变得很不高兴。然后他有一个独白镜头，他说，好吧，听着，我有手足多汗症。好吧。所以我们发现他有这种病，
that makes your feet sweat really, really badly. So I guess he's been taking his shoes off over and accounting. I love this little tidbit and I'm sad it didn't make it in. Well, this explains why when Pam walks into the room, Kevin's feet are up on her chair and his shoes are off. Yes. People wrote in and asked about that. It's because in the deleted scene, Michael is getting everyone to loosen up. And we find out that Kevin has, how do you say it? Hyper hydrosis. Angela, I love that. That's a good catch. That's a good catch. Good tip. Tidbit. Tidbit. It's a Kenzie tidbit. All right. So when Pam does finally get back, they begin again and Dwight is the first one to share. Oh, this is one of my favorite things. And
会让他的脚出汗非常非常严重。所以我想他一直在会计部把鞋子脱掉。我太喜欢这个小花絮了，我很遗憾它没有被剪进正片。好吧，这就解释了为什么当帕姆走进房间时，凯文的脚搭在她的椅子上，而且他的鞋子脱掉了。是的。人们写信来询问过这件事。这是因为在被删减的场景中，迈克尔让每个人都放松下来。我们发现凯文有，你是怎么说的？多汗症。安吉拉，我喜欢这个。这是一个很好的细节捕捉。这是一个很好的细节捕捉。好料。好料。这是肯齐（Kenzie）的小花絮。好吧，所以当帕姆终于回来时，他们重新开始，德怀特是第一个分享的。哦，这是我最喜欢的事情之一。而且
Dwight shares that he was supposed to have a twin, but he absorbed the twin in utero. All right. We had a fan question from Aira Tajali. Did Rainn Wilson make the whole absorbing twin thing up or was it scripted? Well, first of all, I will tell you, it is not in the script. I don't know if Rainn made it up, but in the script, Dwight was supposed to say this. He was supposed to say, in the Blizzard of 97, 12 shrewts died in the basement of our house. They drank beer cider that had already turned. President McKinley declared it a national emergency. Now, my favorite thing about that is that clearly it's not 1997. It's like 1897. Yeah. Yeah. I guess. But that was originally Dwight's grief share.
德怀特分享说他本该有个双胞胎兄弟，但在子宫里把双胞胎给吸收了。好吧。我们有一个来自艾拉·塔贾利（Aira Tajali）的粉丝提问。雷恩·威尔逊是现编的吸收双胞胎这事，还是剧本里写的？嗯，首先，我得告诉你，这不在剧本里。我不知道是不是雷恩现编的，但在剧本里，德怀特本来应该这么说。他本应该说，在97年的暴风雪中，有12只鼩鼱死在我们家的地下室里。它们喝了已经变质的啤酒苹果酒。麦金莱总统（President McKinley）宣布这是一场国家紧急状态。现在，我最喜欢这一点的是，很明显那不是1997年。就像1897年一样。对。对。我想是的。但那是最初德怀特的悲伤分享。
So here's the thing. I reached out to Jen Salad about this, and this is maybe one of my favorite text threads of all time. This is what tickled me so much, is that Jen Salad, Jenna, she's one of our people. She's a deep diver. Yeah. The minute I asked her, she went on a deep dive for the whole afternoon. Ready? So I say, okay, Jen, Dwight's speech about absorbing his twin is not in the script. Was that an improv? Did you tell him on the day? She goes, Oh my God. I don't remember. Oh my God. I love that speech. And sadly, it wasn't mine. I'm going to start texting people. Please hold. Oh, I love this so much. This happened throughout the day. She said, I texted Rain. Rain actually thinks it was an alt pitched from Paul.
所以事情是这样的，我为此联系了简·萨拉达（Jen Salada），这可能是我有生以来最喜欢的短信串之一。最让我开心的是，简·萨拉达，詹娜，她是我们的自己人。她是个深度挖掘者。对。我一问她，她整个下午都在进行深度挖掘。准备好了吗？所以我说，好吧，简，德怀特关于吸收他的双胞胎的演讲不在剧本里。那是即兴发挥吗？你在当天告诉过他吗？她说，哦，天哪。我不记得了。哦，天哪。我太喜欢那段演讲了。遗憾的是，那不是我想的。我要开始给人们发短信了。请保持通话。哦，我太喜欢这个了。这整天都在发生。她说，我给雷恩发了短信。雷恩其实觉得那是保罗（Paul）提出的一个备选方案。
Jen said, here's a side note. I had a friend that reabsorbed his twin, but I definitely didn't come up with the strength of a baby. She said, I'm going to check with Paul where that part came from. Please hold. She texts Paul. Paul says he thinks it was Justin Spitzer. Hold one second. Now texting Justin. Justin was another one of our writers. This is what Justin texted Jen back. I still remember that because it was early season three and I was so nervous about proving myself. I guess, yes, I came up with it. But the thing that really sold it to me was the last line about him having the strength of a grown man plus a baby. And that was something that Paul Lieberstein added after. So I think he deserves a fair amount of credit as well.
简说，这里有个题外话。我有个朋友重新吸收了他的双胞胎，但我绝对没想过婴儿的力量这种事。她说，我要跟保罗核实一下那部分是哪里来的。请保持通话。她给保罗发了短信。保罗说他觉得那是贾斯廷·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）想出来的。等一下。现在给贾斯廷发短信。贾斯廷是我们的另一位编剧。这是贾斯廷回给简的短信。我还记得那是因为那是第三季初，我非常紧张，急于证明自己。我想，是的，是我想出来的。但真正说服我的是最后一句关于他拥有成年男子的力量加一个婴儿的力量。那是保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）后来加上的。所以我觉得他也应得相当多的功劳。
So I'm giving that a slow clap into a big clap. Yes. Wow. It was a two-hander that Paul and Justin pitched. I love that we got to the bottom of that mystery because it is one of my all-time favorite Dwight isms. Also guys, Justin Spitzer is the creator of the show Superstore. Justin is so talented. He's so talented. I love him. Love him. Anyway, I think the only place to go from here is back to our grief circle and we need to hear from some others. Okay. So we're back into the grief counseling scene and Stanley has just refused. He is not going to participate. No. He chunks that ball back at Michael. Hey. Yeah, you heard that. But Pam agrees to participate and she's going to share a story about her family. But it's clearly just the synopsis for the movie Million
所以我对此表示由衷的赞赏。是的。哇。这是保罗和贾斯廷共同提出的双人创意。我很高兴我们查清了这个谜团的底细，因为这是我所有最喜欢的德怀特语录之一。还有，伙计们，贾斯廷·斯皮策是电视剧《超级商店》（Superstore）的创作者。贾斯廷太有才了。他太有才了。我爱他。爱死他了。无论如何，我觉得从这里唯一的去处就是回到我们的悲伤圆圈，我们需要听听其他人的看法。好吧。所以我们回到了悲伤辅导的场景，斯坦利刚刚拒绝了。他才不打算参与呢。不。他把那个球狠狠地砸回给迈克尔。嘿。对，你听到了。但帕姆同意参与，她要分享一个关于她家庭的故事。但这很明显只是电影《百万美元宝贝》（Million Dollar Baby）的剧情简介。
Dollar Baby. Yeah. I mean, again, Pam is now the gym. She's the jokester. Yes. And then Ryan joins in and he shares a story that is very clearly the Lion King. I mean, he says the word Mufasa. I mean, yeah, come on. But then Kevin catches on and he's tickled. He wants to participate. He wants to play the game. But he goes too broad to on the nose and he basically breaks down weekend at Bernie's and Michael's like, what? Hold up. That's a movie and he gets really ticked off. Okay. So there was a lot of curiosity about these movie plots in the conference room. We got a fan question from Tristan, who wants to know when everyone is in the conference room for Michael's counseling session, did the cast improvise the movie plots that were mentioned or were they scripted? Jenna, to my
对。我的意思是，帕姆现在又是吉姆了。她是个爱开玩笑的人。是的。然后瑞安加入了进来，他分享了一个故事，这非常明显就是《狮子王》（The Lion King）。我的意思是，他说出了“木法沙”（Mufasa）这个词。我的意思是，行了吧，拜托。但接着凯文反应过来了，他觉得很有趣。他也想参与。他也想玩这个游戏。但他扯得太宽泛、太直白了，他基本上把《老板度假》（Weekend at Bernie's）的剧情给复述了一遍，迈克尔就说，什么？等一下。那是一部电影，他变得非常生气。好吧。所以大家对会议室里的这些电影情节有很多好奇。我们收到了来自特里斯坦（Tristan）的粉丝提问，他想知道当每个人都在会议室参加迈克尔的辅导课时，演员们是即兴发挥了提到的电影情节，还是剧本里写好的？詹娜，据我
knowledge, they were all scripted. That's how I remember it. Yes. I looked these up in the shooting draft and Pam's Million Dollar Baby story and Kevin's weekend at Bernie's story are both in the script. However, Ryan's fake movie story is different. Ah, yes. In the script, he talks about Thelma and Louise. Well, this is what he says. He says, my mom's sister Thelma died last year. She was with her friend named Lucy. A cop was trying to pull them over. And I guess the breaks must have not been working because they ended up driving over a cliff. And it was a total shock to everyone. Okay. Well, we wanted to get to the bottom of this. So we reached out to the source, the writer of this episode, Jen Salada. And this is what she had to say. For the movies in the
所知，它们全都是剧本写好的。我就是这么记的。是的。我在拍摄初稿中查过，帕姆的《百万美元宝贝》故事和凯文的《老板度假》故事都在剧本里。然而，瑞安的假电影故事是不同的。啊，是的。在剧本里，他谈论的是《末路狂花》（Thelma and Louise）。好吧，他是这么说的。他说，我妈妈的妹妹塞尔玛（Thelma）去年去世了。她和她的一个叫露西（Lucy）的朋友在一起。一个警察试图把他们拦下。我想刹车肯定失灵了，因为他们最后把车开下了悬崖。这对每个人来说都是一个巨大的震惊。好吧。我们想弄个水落石出。所以我们联系了消息源，这集的编剧简·萨拉达。她是这么说的。对于悲伤辅导环节中的电影，我真的很兴奋。这真的很有趣。我脱离了剧本，需要找到一种方法让每个人都能坐在迈克尔·斯科特身边，而不是分享他们自己关于巨大损失的个人故事，因为他们似乎不会那样做。所以我认为他们应该分享电影的情节，就好像那是他们自己的生活一样。我为你，詹娜饰演的帕姆，想出了《百万美元宝贝》，然后对于凯文想出了《老板度假》。至于瑞安，我有一个不同的。我觉得B.J.想出了《狮子王》。我记不太清了，但我觉得是B.J.，我太喜欢那个了。我原本想的那个，我其实找到了我的剧本初稿。我有瑞安的，我读给你听。它没有《狮子王》那个那么好，
grief counseling session, I was really excited. It was really fun to think about. I went off on script and needed to find a way that everybody would sit there with Michael Scott and not share their own personal stories of huge loss because it just didn't seem like they would do that. So I thought they should share movies plot lines as if they were their own lives. And I came up with I came up with million dollar baby for you, Jennifer Pam, and then also for Kevin weekend at Bernie's. And for Ryan, I had a different one. I think BJ came up with the Lion King. I don't quite remember, but I think it was BJ and I love that one. The one I had, I actually found my first draft of the script. I had Ryan, I'll read you the line. It's not as good as the Lion King one,
但我让瑞安说，这简直太可怕了，没法开口，但我有个表弟是个大城市律师，他当时正在离这儿不远的一个阿米什（Amish）小镇参观，结果他在他们的粮仓里被活活闷死了。然后我让迈克尔说，噢，那一定让你很难过吧？是吗？然后瑞安说是的。所以我想那是《目击者》（Witness）里的。我希望我能记得其他一些，因为我觉得我们还有其他一些备选，但那些是我初稿里的。然后，当然，来自《狮子王》的生生不息太棒了。而且瑞安说这大概需要一个半小时才能讲完，这真是一句绝妙的台词。太棒了。顺便说一句，我和我的大学室友过去常常看《目击者》，我们总是对彼此说，在那些英国人中间要小心点。谢谢。那是我从《目击者》中学到的台词。但不是很疯狂吗，詹娜，瑞安的，瑞安的电影经历了三个版本。它是《目击者》，然后，根据你的剧本，它是《末路狂花》，但《狮子王》才是最终进入正片的版本。是的，显然他们为这些电影情节准备了很多备选，但所有这些都是剧本里写好的，伙计们，全部都是由我们优秀的编剧写的。我们可没有即兴发挥那些东西。太棒了。太喜欢这个小花絮了，简·萨拉达。所以伙计们，迈克尔看到大家没有认真对待这件事，变得相当沮丧。你知道，他说那个以前做他的工作并坐在他座位上的人已经去世了，却没有人会在乎。是的。然后托比试图安抚他，
but I have Ryan say this is almost too horrible to talk about, but I had a cousin who was a big city lawyer and he was visiting an Amish town not far from here and he was smothered to death in their grain silo. And then I had Michael say, ooh, that must have made you really sad. Did it? And Ryan says yes. So I think that was a witness. So I had Ryan's from witness. I wish I could remember some of the other ones because I feel like we had other ones that we pitched on, but those were the ones from my first draft. And then of course, the Lion King's circle of life was fantastic. And Ryan saying it'll take about an hour and a half to tell it was like such a great line. That is amazing. By the way, my college roommate and I used to watch witness and we would say to
但是瑞安说这几乎太可怕而难以启齿，但我有个表哥是大城市的律师，他有一次去离这儿不远的一个阿米什小镇参观，结果在他们的粮仓里窒息身亡了。然后迈克尔说，哦，那一定让你很难过吧？是吗？瑞安说是的。所以我觉得那是《目击者》。所以我用了《目击者》里的瑞安。我真希望自己能想起其他的一些，因为我觉得我们还讨论过其他的，但那些是我初稿里的。当然啦，《狮子王》的生生不息太棒了。瑞安说讲完这个得花一个半小时左右，这台词太棒了。太惊艳了。顺便说一下，我和我大学室友以前经常看《目击者》，我们会对
each other all the time, be careful out among them English. Thank you. That is my moving world from witness. But isn't that wild, Jenna, that Ryan's, Ryan's movie went through three versions. It was witness and then it was, I guess, Thelma and Louise, according to your script, but the Lion King is what made it in the show. Yeah, clearly they had a lot of alts for these movie plots, but all of them were scripted guys, all of them written by our awesome writers. We did not improvise that stuff. Love that. Love that little tidbit, Jen Salata. So guys, Michael gets pretty upset that people are not taking this seriously. You know, he says the guy who used to do his job and sit at his desk has died and no one cares. Yeah. And Toby tries to talk him down
并试图解释这只是生活，他今天早上看到一只鸟飞进楼下的窗户然后死掉了。迈克尔抓狂了。哦，天哪，托比。托比，你在想什么呢？他完全把注意力转移到那上面去了。现在迈克尔对埃德的悲伤不知怎么地包裹进了这只鸟里面。这要变成一件大事了。是的。他跑下楼。他抓狂了。他想看看那只鸟是不是还活着。我这里有一个来自肯德拉（Kendra）的粉丝细节捕捉。在14分33秒时，当迈克尔冲过前门去抓那只鸟时，他跑过了保安台，而那个保安不是汉克。哦，捕捉得好。是的，换了个保安。汉克请了个人假，伙计们。我想是的。好吧，迈克尔试图在厨房里对那只鸟进行心肺复苏。安吉拉，你很不高兴。
and tries to explain that this is just life and that this morning he saw a bird fly into the window downstairs and die. Michael freaks out. Oh my gosh, Toby. Toby, what are you thinking? He totally attaches to that. Now Michael's grief for Ed is somehow wrapped into this bird. It's going to be a whole thing. Yeah. He runs downstairs. He freaks out. He wants to see if the bird is alive. I had a fan catch here from Kendra. At 14 minutes 33 seconds when Michael runs through the front door to get the bird, he runs past the security desk and the security guard is not Hank. Oh, good catch. Yeah, different security guard. Hank took a personal day, you guys. I guess so. Well, Michael attempts to resuscitate the bird in the kitchen. Angela, you're not pleased.
所以迈克尔决心要救活这只鸟。他把它带进了厨房。安吉拉·马丁很不高兴。她就像，不，那不应该在这里。拿出去。好吧，她非常不高兴，而且安吉拉，她并没有错。谢谢。谢谢你，詹娜。不客气。不客气。我们收到了来自埃利·弗里德兰德（Ellie Friedlander）的粉丝提问。她想知道，那是一只真的死鸟吗？不。不，不。那是一只假鸟。我联系了菲尔（Phil）。他告诉我他找到了三个死假鸟选项，并把它们呈献给了我们的导演简·罗杰（Jen Roger）和格雷格（Greg）。他们选择了你在剧本里看到的那只。而且安吉拉，我不得不说，当他给我回短信说他呈献了三只死鸟时，我在脑海中想象它们是放在一个银盘上的，因为记得吗，菲尔总是会把你的道具放在一个银盘上呈献给你。是的，是的。我当时就在想象。我回复他说，菲尔，它们是放在银盘上的吗？他说，你太了解我了。听着，这些就是我们剧中的那些时刻，我会说，嘿，宝贝，你今天过得怎么样？你今天做什么了？嗯，我得找三只假死鸟。是的。就像格雷格回家时，他的妻子苏茜（Susie）问，嘿，亲爱的，今天拍摄进展如何？他说，太棒了。我挑了一只死鸟。是的。我挑了黄的那只。我挑选了我的死鸟。是的，完全如此。好吧，迈克尔随后对员工说，注意，注意，我们将在下午4点在停车场为这只鸟举行葬礼。务必到场。就这样。詹娜，现在我觉得是时候回过头来看看吉姆和凯伦了。
So Michael is determined to save this bird. He brings it into the kitchen. Angela Martin is not pleased. She's like, no, that shouldn't be in here. Get it out. Well, she is not pleased and Angela, she's not wrong. Thank you. Thank you, Jenna. You're welcome. You're welcome. We had a fan question from Ellie Friedlander. She wants to know, was that a real dead bird? No. No, no. It was a fake bird. I reached out to Phil. He told me that he found three dead fake bird options and presented them to Jen, Roger, our director, and Greg. They chose the one that you see in the show. And Angela, I have to say, when he texted me back that he presented the three dead birds, I imagined in my head that they were on a silver tray, because remember, Phil would always present
所以迈克尔决心拯救这只鸟。他把它带进了厨房。安吉拉·马丁很不高兴。她觉得，不行，这不该在这儿。把它弄出去。嗯，她确实很不高兴，而安吉拉，她说得也没错。谢谢。谢谢你，詹娜。不客气。不客气。我们收到了来自埃莉·弗里德兰德的粉丝提问。她想知道，那是一只真的死鸟吗？不是。不，不，那是只假鸟。我联系了菲尔。他告诉我说他找到了三个死鸟的假模型选项，并把它们呈给了我们的导演詹·罗杰和格列格。他们选中了你在剧里看到的那个。而且安吉拉，我得说，当他回信告诉我他呈上了那三只死鸟时，我在脑海中想象它们是被放在一个银盘里的，因为记得吗，菲尔总是会呈现
you your props on a silver tray. Yes, yes. And I was just imagining it. I wrote it back and I said, Phil, were they on a silver tray? And he said, you know me too well. Listen, these are the moments in our show where I'm like, hey, babe, how was your day? What did you do today? Well, I had to find three fake dead birds. Yeah. Like when Greg goes home and his wife, Susie, is like, hey, hon, how'd it go shooting today? He's like, great. I picked a dead bird. Yeah. I picked the yellow one. I made my dead bird selection. Yes, exactly. Well, Michael then tells the staff, attention, attention, we are holding a funeral for this bird at 4 p.m. in the parking lot. Be there. It's on. Jenna, now I think it's time to check back in on Jim and Karen.
哦，是的。他们找到薯片了吗？他们在哪里？他们在哪里寻找这包很难找到的薯片？其实就在自动售货机里。那可能在自动售货机里。那就在自动售货机里。根据粉丝捕捉，那是自动售货机里的B1。它就在那里等着他们呢。好吧，凯伦有点给吉姆留下了深刻印象，因为她决定给蒙特利尔（Montreal）打电话，给蒙特利尔工厂打电话看他们有没有货。而且她说法语。我们可以吗？很多人写信来讨论这件事。布里安娜·布勒（Breanna Bullard）和许许多多其他人想知道雷希达·琼斯（Rashida Jones）真的懂法语吗？所以我给雷希达发了短信，既然我们已经在发关于她早餐点单的短信了。她大概在想，安吉拉，这到底是怎么回事？她是这么说的。她
Oh, yes. Have they found the chips? Where are they? Where are they in their search for this very hard to find potato chip bag? That's actually in the vending machine. That might be in the vending machine. That is in the vending machine. That is according to a fan catch is B1 in the vending machine. It's right there waiting for them. Well, Karen kind of impresses Jim because she decides to call Montreal, the Montreal factory to see if they have them. And she speaks French. May we? A lot of people wrote in about this. Breanna Bullard and many, many others want to know does Rashida Jones actually know French? So I texted Rashida since we're already texting about her breakfast order. She's probably like, Angela, what is happening? This is what she said. She
说，不，那个时候我不懂法语。我为那句台词下了很大功夫。但几年后，我最终去了法国，在法国南部上了一个法语沉浸式学校。也许这个场景是个开始，它启发了我。哇。太疯狂了。她不会说法语，但现在她会了。是的。我当时想，我也想去法国南部的法语沉浸班。听起来太棒了。一样。一样。我在高中学过法语。你学过？哦，我其实有个关于这个的故事。是的。我能快速讲一下吗？行啊。我在兰德里修女（Sister Landry）那里上过高中法语课。我进了一所天主教学校。兰德里修女是我的法语老师。我梦想着。我以前告诉过你们，我从小就梦想着有一天我能去
goes, no, at this time, I didn't know French. I worked really hard on that line. But a few years later, I ended up going to France to do a French immersion school in the south of France. Maybe this scene was the beginning and it got me inspired. Wow. That's crazy. She did not speak French, but now she does. Yes. I was like, I want to go to a French immersion class in the south of France. That sounds amazing. Same. Same. I took French in high school. You did? Oh, I have a story about that actually. Yeah. Can I tell this real quickly? Yeah. I took French in high school from Sister Landry. I went to a Catholic school. Sister Landry was my French teacher. And I dreamed. I told you guys this before I dreamed from the time I was a little girl that I would one day go to
她说，不，那时候我还不会说法语。我为那句台词下了很大功夫。但几年后，我最终去了法国，在法国南部上了一所法语沉浸式学校。也许这场戏是个开端，它给了我灵感。哇。太疯狂了。她以前不会说法语，但现在会了。是的。我当时就想，我想去法国南部上法语沉浸式班。听起来太棒了。同感。同感。我高中时学过法语。你学过？哦，我其实有个关于这个的故事。对。我能快速讲一下吗？好。我高中时跟兰德里修女学过法语。我上的是天主教学校。兰德里修女是我的法语老师。我曾梦想过。我以前跟你们说过，我从小就梦想着有一天能去
Paris. And then in my 30s, that finally happened. Of course, at this point, I was now very far from my French training. Couldn't really speak French. But Lee and I, we went to a little farmer's market and I guess in France, you don't touch the fruit. Okay. You don't select your own produce. You point to it or you trust the person selling the produce to select the best pieces for you. I didn't know this. Okay. Oh my gosh. I would have been, I pick up things. I thump them. I smell them. No, lady. Don't do it. If you go to a farmer's market in France, here's my hot tip for you. Don't thump the melon. Don't thump the melon. Don't thump the melon in France. Okay. Now, all through this trip, we've been going to restaurants and we've been going to tourist
巴黎。然后在我30多岁的时候，这终于发生了。当然，到了这个时候，我离我的法语训练已经非常遥远了。其实已经不会说法语了。但是李和我，我们去了一个小农贸市场，我想在法国，你不能碰水果。好吧。你不能自己挑农产品。你要指着它，或者你相信卖农产品的人会为你挑出最好的部分。我不知道这一点。好吧。哦天哪。我本来会，我拿起东西。我敲它们。我闻它们。不，女士。别这么做。如果你去法国的农贸市场，这是我给你的温馨提示。别敲那个甜瓜。别敲那个甜瓜。别敲那个甜瓜。在法国。好吧。现在，在整个这次旅行中，我们一直在去餐馆，我们一直在去旅游
places and I was just fumbling with my French. I couldn't get anything out. I could read the menus but I couldn't order anything. I thought I was going to really help us but I couldn't help us. But here we are. We're at this little market. I have done the faux pas, I believe that's French, the faux pas of touching the fruit and this woman turns to her co-worker and goes off on me. She in French is calling me like, kind of like a dumb American. Your piece of trash. Yeah, basically, whatever it was, just these Americans come here and they touch her fruit. She was like going on, okay, in French. I was this mixture of just like embarrassed but also felt like, I'm sorry. How was I supposed to know that? I'm a nice person. I'm not a bad person. I'm
地方，我一直在用我笨拙的法语应付。我什么也说不出来。我能看懂菜单，但我什么也点不了。我以为我真的能帮上忙，但我却帮不上忙。但我们现在在这里。我们在小市场上。我犯了一个禁忌，我相信那是法语里的词，犯了摸水果的禁忌，这个女人转过身对她的同事大发雷霆。她用法语把我骂得狗血淋头，有点像个愚蠢的美国人。你的垃圾。是的，基本上，不管是什么，只是这些美国人来到这里，碰了她的水果。她就在那里喋喋不休，好吧，用法语。我当时的心情真是既尴尬又觉得，对不起。我怎么可能知道呢？我是个好人。我不是个坏人。我
sorry I picked up that banana. Angela, this fluent French spilled out of my mouth at this woman and in French, I suddenly had the command to say, I'm so sorry but in the United States, we pick our own fruit. I didn't know about your custom. I apologize but you don't need to say nasty things about me and the look on her face was like, oh, because she certainly didn't think that the fruit touching American could speak French or understand French. And by the way, I didn't know that I had such a command of the language until I was insulted in a farmer's market in Paris. And then your superpower came out. Yes. You know how like some superheroes, their power doesn't come through until they're in crisis. I was like a mom lifting a car off
对不起，我拿了那根香蕉。安吉拉，一口流利的法语从我的嘴里倾泻而出，对着这个女人，在法语中，我突然有能力说，非常抱歉，但在美国，我们自己挑水果。我不知道你们的风俗。我道歉，但你不需要说我的坏话，她脸上的表情就像是，哦，因为她肯定没想到这个摸水果的美国人会说法语或听得懂法语。顺便说一句，我不知道自己对这门语言的掌握程度这么好，直到我在巴黎的一个农贸市场被侮辱了。然后你的超能力就爆发了。是的。你知道有些超级英雄，他们的超能力在危机来临之前是不会显现的。我就像一个把汽车从
her baby. Yeah, exactly. All right, so now we're back at Dunder Mifflin and Kelly is crying by the copier in the annex. Yeah. She is in tears. Michael thinks he's finally made a breakthrough until she reveals that she's really crying about her plans with Ryan. I have a question about this scene. Okay. What is up with this second copier in the annex? Is it always there? I have never seen it before. What is happening? I think they just rolled it in from the bullpen for the scene. I feel like they did and they did it because in the background, in the breakroom, Dwight is in there. You can see him over Kelly's shoulder trying to shove this bird into an empty soda can. I feel like that's why they had to put the copier there to combine these two moments,
她婴儿身上抬起来的母亲。 yeah，没错。好了，现在我们回到了邓德米夫林，凯莉正在附楼的复印机旁哭泣。是的。她泪流满面。迈克尔以为他终于取得了突破，直到她透露她其实是在为她和瑞安的计划哭泣。我对这个场景有个问题。好吧。附楼里的这台第二台复印机是怎么回事？它一直都在那里吗？我以前从来没见过它。这是怎么回事？我觉得他们只是把它从大办公室推过来拍这场戏的。我觉得他们确实这么做了，他们这么做是因为在背景里，在茶水间里，德怀特在那儿。你可以看到他越过凯莉的肩膀，试图把这只鸟塞进一个空苏打罐里。我觉得这就是他们为什么必须把复印机放在那里以结合这两个时刻，
to have a reason for Michael to be back there. Right. And for him to see over his shoulder and all of that, exactly. That copier did not live there in that hallway. They just shoved it there. Yeah. I did not think so. I feel like I will track this. It's going to be a soft track, but I am going to look for this copier more. I think it should be a very soft track because I would be bold enough to say, I think it might be the only time it's in the annex. I know that's setting myself up for some fan mail of like Angela actually in season eight, but I'm just saying, I don't think that copier visits the annex very often. Guys, if you're watching another episode and you see that copier right to us,
给迈克尔一个理由回到后面去。没错。还有让他越过肩膀看之类的，完全正确。那台复印机平时不住在那条走廊里。他们只是把它塞到那儿了。 yeah。我可不这么认为。我觉得我要追踪这个。这将是一个冷门追踪，但我会更多地寻找这台复印机。我觉得它应该是一个非常冷门的追踪，因为我敢大胆地说，我觉得这可能是它唯一一次出现在附楼里。我知道这会给我招来一些粉丝来信，比如安吉拉其实在第八季里……但我只是说，我觉得那台复印机不经常去附楼。伙计们，如果你在看另一集，看到那台复印机，写信给我们，
you can go to our website, officeladies.com and submit questions or comments or write to us at officeladies at yourwolf.com. Here we go. We want to know. We want to know. All right, but this leads us into one of my favorite Dwight talking heads, where he explains, he's justifying why is he shoving this bird into a can and it's because he grew up on a farm. Yeah. And guys, they reburied his grandfather in an old oil drum. Okay, hold on. I mean, the same grandfather that was buried in the suit that he wore, like what's happening? How many times has this guy been brought up out of the ground? This is one of my favorite things about our show. Teresa S also loves it. She wrote in to say,
你可以访问我们的网站 officeladies.com，提交问题或评论，或者发邮件到 officeladies at yourwolf.com。我们来了。我们想知道。我们想知道。好吧，但这引出了我最喜欢的德怀特的访谈之一，他在其中解释，他正在为自己为什么要硬把这只鸟塞进罐子里辩解，这是因为他在农场长大的。是的。伙计们，他们把他爷爷重新埋在了一个旧油桶里。好吧，等等。我是说，就是那个穿着他生前穿的西装下葬的爷爷，这是怎么回事？这家伙被从地里挖出来多少次了？这是我们节目中我最喜欢的事情之一。特蕾莎·S也很喜欢。她写信说，
in Casino Night, Dwight says that his grandfather was buried in the tuxedo he's wearing. Yeah. And in grief counseling, he said his grandfather was reburied in an oil drum. Reburied? She wrote, reburied. What happened? What is the story behind Dwight's grandfather? Was he exhumed for some reason? And did Dwight take the tuxedo off his dead grandfather before reburying him? And then fold him up. It sounds like it. Then he folded him up and tried to shove him in a drum. Teresa, that's exactly what it sounds like. This is some of my favorite writing on our show. In that moment in Casino Night, when Dwight just says he's wearing a tuxedo, my grandfather was buried in it. That's it. We say no more about it. And then three episodes later,
在《赌场之夜》中，德怀特说他的爷爷穿着他身上这套燕尾服下葬。是的。而在《悲伤辅导》中，他说他的爷爷被重新埋在一个油桶里。重新埋葬？她写道，重新埋葬。发生了什么事？德怀特爷爷的故事背景是什么？他是不是因为某种原因被挖出来了？德怀特在重新埋葬他死去的爷爷之前，有没有把燕尾服从他爷爷身上脱下来？然后把他叠起来。听起来是这样的。然后他把他叠起来，试图把他塞进一个桶里。特蕾莎，听起来确实是这样。这是我们节目中我最喜欢的一些剧本。在《赌场之夜》的那一刻，当德怀特只是说他穿着一件燕尾服，我爷爷穿着它下葬。就是这样。我们对此闭口不谈。然后三集之后，
he's like, when my grandfather was reburied. And it's like, slowly, it's all coming together. Sort of. Sort of. Not completely. This is one of my favorite bits of how our show is written. So now we're at reception, right? And Pam has prepared this really beautiful box for the bird funeral. I mean, it is amazing, the attention to detail. She asked Dwight if he would perhaps want to play a song. She's like, do you have your recorder? He's like, always, always has. Always. Always. And, and, you know, Pam has this really sweet talking head where she's like, well, you know what? I didn't anticipate I'd be throwing a bird funeral today, but you never know working here. That's right. We had a fan question from Andrew S. Did Jenna make the box for the bird
他说，当我爷爷被重新埋葬的时候。这就好比，慢慢地，一切都串联起来了。算是吧。算是吧。并不完全是。这是我们节目编写方式中我最喜欢的片段之一。所以现在我们在前台，对吧？帕姆为鸟葬准备了一个非常漂亮的盒子。我是说，太惊人了，对细节的关注。她问德怀特是否想演奏一首曲子。她说，你带竖笛了吗？他说，一直带着，总是带着。一直。一直。而且，你知道，帕姆有一段非常甜蜜的访谈，她说，好吧，你知道吗，我没预料到今天会办一场鸟葬，但在这里工作你永远不知道。没错。我们有一个来自安德鲁·S的粉丝提问：詹娜是自己做的这个鸟葬的盒子吗？
funeral herself? Or was that a Phil Shea creation? Either way, how was it constructed? Well, guys, I did not make it. Phil Shea made it. He said he actually made a few options and presented them again to Jen and Roger and Greg. They picked the one that they liked. And then Phil had to make multiples of it because, you know, it gets set on fire. Yeah. So he had to make a whole bunch of those. I looked it up in the script and it was described in the script. So here's what Phil had to go off of. It said, it is a hollowed out tissue box with tissue padding in the center for the bird to lie on. And the outside is decorated in tissue paper and has a tiny little toothpick cross. My favorite part are the the handles. The handles made out of the pencils.
还是菲尔·谢a的作品？不管怎样，它是怎么制作的？好吧，伙计们，不是我做的。是菲尔·谢a做的。他说他实际上做了几个选择，然后再次向詹、罗杰和格雷格展示。他们选了他们喜欢的那个。然后菲尔不得不制作多个，因为，你知道的，它要被烧掉。是的。所以他不得不制作一大堆那样的东西。我在剧本里查过，剧本里是这样描述的。所以菲尔是根据这个来制作的：上面写着，这是一个挖空的纸巾盒，中间有纸巾垫，供鸟躺在上面。外面用纸巾纸装饰，还有一个小小的牙签十字架。我最喜欢的部分是把手。用铅笔做的把手。
So that was a Phil addition. That was just Phil. Yeah. Yeah. He needed to make sure that tiny bird casket had little bars for his the pallbearers. That's right. The tiny pallbearers. Yes, we are going to wrap things up in Stamford now. Guys, Jim found the chips. He left them on her desk. He's quite pleased with himself. Yeah, I really wanted my mom to record a sting that said flirty Jim, but we we couldn't we couldn't get it together. Oh, well, these scenes drove people crazy. I went back and looked at some of the comments from when this air. Oh, here is what they said. D temp said, I feel kind of weird about Jim and Karen. But Hartman said, the Karen thing. Why? Oh, why am I liking it? But I am. Whoa. I remember people freaking out about it.
所以那是菲尔的添加。那只是菲尔的创意。是的。是的。他需要确保那个微小的鸟棺材有小栏杆给抬棺人。没错。微小的抬棺人。是的，我们现在要把斯坦福的事情收尾了。伙计们，吉姆找到了薯片。他把它们忘在她的桌上了。他对自己很满意。是的，我真的很想让我妈妈录一段台词，说“调情的吉姆”，但我们没能凑齐。哦，好吧，这些场景把人们迷得神魂颠倒。我回去看了一些这一集播出时的评论。哦，这是他们说的。D temp说，我对吉姆和凯伦感觉有点奇怪。但哈特曼说，关于凯伦的事。为什么？哦，为什么我会喜欢它？但我确实喜欢。哇。我记得人们对此疯狂不已。
Well, Keely said, Jim and Karen have great chemistry. And Mandy said, OK, I'm sorry, I can't believe there are actually people out there who are OK with Jim hooking up with Karen. That's what I remember. But Kim E said this, hmm, Jim likes to buy chips for all his ladies. And I'm with you, Kim. As Pam, I'm like, Oh, is this what you do? You just find all the girls their favorite chips? Yeah, that's his game. Are we saying that right? Oh, is that your game? You and I? I 100% doubt we are. Sam's giving us an OK. Sam gave us an OK. That's his game. All right, should we go to this bird funeral, Angela? I can't wait. Please take me there. Well, we're out in the driveway, really next to the warehouse. This was an actual parking lot
嗯，基利说，吉姆和凯伦很有化学反应。曼迪说，好吧，对不起，我不敢相信居然有人能接受吉姆和凯伦勾搭在一起。这就是我所记得的。但金·E是这么说的，嗯，吉姆喜欢给他的所有女士买薯片。我和你一样，金。作为帕姆，我想，哦，这就是你的套路吗？你只是给所有的女孩找她们最喜欢的薯片？是的，这就是他的游戏。我们说得对吗？哦，这是你的游戏吗？你和我？我百分之百怀疑我们不是。萨姆向我们比了个OK。萨姆给我们比了个OK。这就是他的游戏。好吧，我们去参加这个鸟葬吧，安吉拉？我等不及了。请带我去吧。好吧，我们在车道上，紧挨着仓库。这是一个我们用过的实际停车场，
that we used, and it was right next to the warehouse. And that's where we filmed this. Michael is very moved by Pam's beautiful coffin. It starts with Pam saying a few words about the bird. But we slowly realized that Pam is speaking about the bird, but she's speaking to Michael. About his feelings about death and loss. And about his aloneness. She talks a lot about how just because the bird was alone doesn't mean he was unloved, that he was very loved and respected by the other birds. And then she sings a song. I was very surprised by this for Pam. She really put herself out there. She sings on the wings of love. She's accompanied by Dwight on the recorder. Michael is very moved. He's holding hands. He's swaying. He's tearing up.
它就在仓库旁边。这就是我们拍摄的地方。迈克尔被帕姆漂亮的棺材深深打动了。开场是帕姆对这只鸟说了几句话。但我们慢慢意识到帕姆是在谈论这只鸟，但她是在对迈克尔说话。关于他对于死亡和失去的感受。以及关于他的孤独。她谈了很多，仅仅因为这只鸟孤独并不意味着它不被爱，它受到了其他鸟类的爱戴和尊重。然后她唱了一首歌。我对帕姆的这个举动感到非常惊讶。她真的豁出去了。她唱了《爱之翼》。德怀特用竖笛给她伴奏。迈克尔非常感动。他握着手。他摇晃着。他含泪了。
We got a lot of questions about this scene. Richard H. really covers them all. He says, did Rain already know how to play the recorder? Did Jenna sing the entire song? Or did the singing end where the scene was cut? He also wanted to know, did we rehearse our duet? Here's what I can tell you. Yes, Rain knew how to play the recorder. Remember, he played it in Take Your Daughter to Work Day. He's actually very good. But listen to all of the instruments that Rain can play in real life, Angela. He can play the recorder, piano, clarinet, saxophone, bassoon, guitar, drums, xylophone, bells, and a little tuba and baritone. What are you, a one-man band, Rain? He kind of is. I knew you could play the bassoon because your book, The Bassoon King, is great.
我们收到了很多关于这个场景的问题。理查德·H真的把它们都涵盖了。他说，雷恩已经会吹竖笛了吗？詹娜是唱完整首歌了吗？还是歌声在场景剪辑的地方结束了？他还想知道，我们排练过二重唱吗？我可以告诉你的是：是的，雷恩会吹竖笛。记住，他在《带女儿上班日》里吹过。他其实吹得非常好。但听听雷恩在现实生活中能演奏的所有乐器，安吉拉。他会吹竖笛、钢琴、单簧管、萨克斯、大管、吉他、架子鼓、木琴、铃铛，还有一点大号和次中音号。你是什么，一人乐队吗，雷恩？他差不多是的。我知道你会吹大管，因为你的书《大管之王》很棒。
So I knew that. But I didn't know you were walking one-man show. Suffice it to say, Rain knew his stuff. And we did rehearse, but just a little bit right before the scene. Rain and I practiced separately. I had listened to the song over and over again to memorize the words. I had to sing the first verse through the chorus. That's what I had to do over and over again. I was so nervous. Well, I thought you did fantastic. Thank you. I have a fan question from the scene, Jenna. Okay. So Chelsea wrote in and said, was Angela's a man improvised? A lot of people wrote in about this because it was so quick after Pam is done talking. People wanted to know if I improvised that. No, that was scripted. And folks wanted to know why did Angela do it? And
所以我知道这一点。但我不知道你还是个行走的单人秀。总之，雷恩对他的东西了如指掌。我们确实排练过，但在开拍前只排练了一小会儿。雷恩和我分别进行了练习。我把这首歌听了一遍又一遍来背歌词。我得从第一段主歌一直唱到副歌。这就是我一遍又一遍不得不做的事情。我太紧张了。嗯，我觉得你表现棒极了。谢谢。我有一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，詹娜。好吧。所以切尔西写信说，安吉拉的“阿门”是即兴发挥的吗？很多人写信来问这个，因为在帕姆说完话之后，这个词出现得太快了。人们想知道我是不是即兴发挥的。不，那是剧本里写的。人们想知道安吉拉为什么要这么做，而且
I said, I think personally, the direction that, you know, they gave me was that Angela had had enough of this charade, this bird funeral. Pam had gone on and on enough. Amen. I'm done. And that... That's how you finish it. Yes. Amen. I'm finished. Amen. Stop talking. Yes, exactly. Speaking of the script, I have a script catch. Okay. So, you know, in the scene, we set the box on fire. In the shooting draft of the script, we buried the bird. There was a scene where Michael and Dwight are digging a hole outside and then we all gather around this hole. And it got changed to fire, but I don't know why. I think maybe Angela, there was really no grass in this area that we shot. We had no grass. There was a hedge with maybe like, I don't know,
我个人认为，他们给我的指导是，安吉拉已经受够了这个荒唐的鸟葬闹剧。帕姆已经说得够多了，没完没了了。阿门。我受够了。这就是你结束它的方式。是的。阿门。我完成了。阿门。别说了。是的，完全正确。说到剧本，我发现了一个剧本bug。好吧。所以，你知道，在那个场景中，我们把盒子点燃了。在剧本的拍摄初稿中，我们埋葬了这只鸟。有一个场景是迈克尔和德怀特在外面挖一个洞，然后我们都聚集在这个洞周围。后来改成了火葬，但我不知道为什么。我想也许，安吉拉，我们拍摄的这个地区真的没有草。我们没有草。那里有一道树篱，可能只有，我不知道，
three feet of dirt. Like, yeah, there was, I mean, not even. There is a deleted scene where Michael and Dwight are trying to dig a hole there and then the business on the other side yells at them and they run away. Oh, okay. Well, there you go. Well, we had another fan question about this fire then. Clara Johnson wants to know, did you actually set the bird on fire? Yes. Real fire fake bird. Kent told me they had to hire a special effects guy to oversee the fire and the extinguishing and they had to get a special permit to be allowed to set the fire. And he said we did three takes, three takes of the fire. And Phil told me, though, that the special effects guys were worried that the fake dead bird might give off toxic fumes when it burned.
三英尺的泥土。就像，是的，我是说，甚至都没有。有一个被删减的场景，迈克尔和德怀特试图在那里挖一个洞，然后另一边的员工对他们大喊大叫，他们就跑开了。哦，好吧。好吧，那就这样吧。好吧，我们对这场大火还有另一个粉丝提问。克拉拉·约翰逊想知道，你们真的把那只鸟点着了吗？是的。真火假鸟。肯特告诉我，他们不得不聘请一个特效师来监督火灾和灭火，他们还必须获得特别许可才能被允许生火。他说我们拍了三次，拍了三次火。菲尔告诉我，特效人员担心那只假死鸟在燃烧时可能会释放出有毒烟雾。
So we, they actually took it out of the box and just put a wad of toilet paper in there. Oh, not toilet paper. I know. Too soon. Too soon, Angela. Too soon. And then finally, we had a fan catch from Peter Kay. He said, I noticed the box was burned in some shredded paper. Could this be further evidence that Pam does use the shredder? Oh, look at that. Nice one, Peter. It would appear so. Well, you know, Jen actually left us a really great message about this scene. And she was talking about the fact that we never got to shoot outside. And when we did, everyone would get really excited. And she explains a little bit about that. So, Sam, can you play that?
所以我们，他们实际上把它从盒子里拿出来，里面只塞了一团卫生纸。哦，不是卫生纸。我知道。为时过早。太早了，安吉拉。太早了。最后，我们有来自彼得·凯的粉丝发现。他说，我注意到盒子里烧着一些碎纸。这是否能进一步证明帕姆确实使用了碎纸机？哦，看那个。干得好，彼得。看来是的。好吧，你知道，詹实际上给我们留了一条关于这个场景的非常棒的信息。她谈到了我们从不在室外拍摄的事实，每当我们在室外拍摄时，每个人都会非常兴奋。她对此做了一些解释。所以，萨姆，你能播放一下吗？
One thing that I remember from the grief counseling episode is that when I went to the sound mix, they were showing us the playback of the episode. And it was still a little bit unusual when the characters went outside. It was still a little bit of a treat. So we get to this bird funeral scene. And our characters are outside. And I just remember hearing kind of an enormous amount of birds. And I think that it was because we were outside, it was because we had a bird funeral. Um, it was so exciting for the amazing sound people who do a fantastic job to put a lot of bird noises in because for the longest time when we're inside the office, they're just putting dot matrix printer sounds and just faxes and old fashioned office noises. So it must have been such
我从《悲伤辅导》这一集里记住的一件事是，当我去声音混音室时，他们正在给我们播放这一集的重放。当角色们走到室外时，这仍然有点不寻常。这仍然算是一种小小的款待。所以我们到了这个鸟葬场景。我们的角色在室外。我只记得听到了一种数量惊人的鸟叫声。我想那是因为我们在室外，因为我们有一场鸟葬。嗯，对于那些做得非常棒的出色音效人员来说，这太令人兴奋了，他们加入了很多鸟叫声，因为很长一段时间里，当我们在办公室里面时，他们只是加入点阵打印机的声音，传真机和老式的办公室声音。所以这一定是一次
a treat and a field day to be able to go outside and hear birds and especially on theme with the funeral. So I remember, this is a slight exaggeration, but it sounded a little bit like Alfred Hitchcock, the birds when the first, when I first heard the playback for the bird funeral. But they quickly made a wonderful adjustment and it was the right amount of outside birds. I love that. I love that our sound mixers got so excited. They put like hundreds of birds and they're like, okay, guys, there's not many birds outside. Let's dial it back. Yes. Yes. Oh, what good insight from Jen this week. Yes. Thank you so much, Jen Salada, for sending in those clips and for texting me. You are amazing. We so appreciate it. And thank you Rashida for
很好的享受和狂欢，能够走到室外听到鸟叫声，而且特别符合葬礼的主题。所以我记得，这有点夸张，但当我第一次听到鸟葬的重放时，听起来有点像阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克的《群鸟》。但他们很快做出了绝妙的调整，那是适量的室外鸟叫声。我喜欢这样。我喜欢我们的音效混音师如此兴奋。他们放了成百上千只鸟，然后他们想，好吧，伙计们，外面没有那么多鸟。让我们把它调小一点。是的。是的。本周詹给我们带来了多么好的见解。是的。非常感谢詹·萨拉达发送这些剪辑并给我发短信。你太棒了。我们非常感激。也谢谢雷希达昨天
letting me bug you about all kinds of random things yesterday. And also Phil Shea and Kent Subornac. Thank you guys for helping us make this podcast so great. And thanks so much to Mindy Kaling for letting us take a clip from your book. Is everyone hanging out without me and other concerns? It's hilarious. We love you Mindy. So there you have it guys. That's the grief counseling episode. Did we do it? Are we leaving you depressed? I hope not. I hope not. And hopefully next week we won't have any more dead birds to tell you about in our lives. Stay safe out there flying friends. Stay safe out there everyone. We love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive
让我为各种乱七八糟的事烦你。还有菲尔·谢a和肯特·苏博纳克。谢谢你们帮助我们把这个播客做得这么棒。非常感谢米歇尔·卡林允许我们引用你书中的一段话。大家都在没有我的情况下出去玩以及其他担忧吗？太搞笑了。我们爱你，米歇尔。所以你们有了，伙计们。这就是《悲伤辅导》那一集。我们做到了吗？我们是不是让你们感到沮丧了？希望没有。希望没有。希望下周我们的生活中不会再有任何死鸟要告诉你们了。飞行的朋友们，在外出时注意安全。大家在外出时注意安全。我们爱你们。谢谢你们收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由
produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科.我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。有关《Office Ladies》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 StitcherPremium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 Office。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。